what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
I have two guests not one not not one
but two guest host today with Sarah
Garvey that's me and Auntie Jenny
before we start um I have a couple
announcements before we start the show
the first is that we have two clips
channels the first is just Pearl eclipse
and the second is Pearl daily
um the second is that we have four
membership tiers if you want to be a
part of the live chat today make sure
you sign up for our five dollar tier
it's the price of a cup of coffee a
month so sign up for that if you want to
be a part of the live chat the second
tier is our Discord and our behind the
scenes Vlogs third tier is to connect
with me on social media and the fourth
tier is a one-on-one call with me once a
month on top of that guys they took away
my Instagram so go follow my new one
just pearly things one they also took
away four of my tick tocks so just go go
follow just probably things dot five and
just probably think six in case they
take away the fifth one um because I am
in one of my final warnings
um
well okay they have never taken you know
I'm not I'm not gonna I'm Not Gonna
Knock on Wood we're also on Rumble guys
the link to that is in the description
um also we have a new channel which is
Pearl behind the scenes make sure you go
subscribe to that I freestyle on that
one so if you guys want to see me
freestyle go subscribe to Pearl behind
the scenes oh gosh
um
also
um d pregame show if you
subscribe to wife school we have our
first episode coming out this week and
today is our last show this week we have
our 100th episode on Monday so
um get ready for that also um I haven't
something I have to read but I don't
have it up yet so sorry why don't you
talk about the topic really quick right
the topic today
is sign language
and communication and how
do men communicate and how do women
communicate but before we even get there
pal tell them if you have watched two or
more of our videos and you have not
subscribed then we have what Pearl beef
what do we have beef exactly so you
better get doing that right now but
before we get started we have some
people here with us wait I need to read
one thing one thing one thing okay guys
we have a sponsor today and I almost
forgot but I did it okay so
um today's sponsor is what is going on
now with inflate inflation is
unprecedented we have never seen
inflation like this before considering
what could be coming next for our
country it is important to get educated
our new 401K Savings Plan hop on a
one-on-one web conference call led by
Harvard train economic and Analysis to
learn how Americans are protecting and
growing their retirement savings
um the link to that is in the
description guys Augusta precious metals
is promoted and used by Hall of Fame
quarterback Joe Montana it has an A plus
BB Better Business Bureau rating with
zero complaints 4.9 out of 5 stars on
consumer affairs highly trusted in the
industry and
remember there's always a risk of loss
and past performance is not indicative
of future results but
um that's the disclaimer but yeah go the
link to that is in the description
all right so yeah we're not here by
ourselves we're not here we're just
aren't genuine you well we have some
guests so
let's introduce our guests and guess if
you can go around and give us your name
your age your relationship status and a
fun fact about you we'll start with you
uh so hi guys my name is Naomi belly I
am 29 years old fun facts are you single
are you married I'm single
and I can't think of a fun fact I always
thought I want to spot people say that
what's up
it's like a really awkward question that
would just be a fun fact that you know
it doesn't even have to be about you I
can't think on the spot maybe a fun fact
is I used to play basketball for grade
and I don't know if that's a fun day
next I'm Nina Rose singer-songwriter
um entrepreneur and the underscore Nina
rose on Twitter and Instagram a fun fact
about me is I'm traveling to one of my
favorite places in the world in two
weeks Ghana let's go are you single are
you married oh I'm single 29
hi guys my name is Georgette I am 31
single and
I did the same thing on the phone vax my
brain empties yeah
obvious so you're not very fun yeah I'm
really boring person yeah at the back
we'll go for you
what's going on people I'll go buy a
beard gang 28 taken and a fun fact is
I'm gonna help Sarah
save his beard apparently he's gonna
help me connect my beard so I've got his
products now and apparently listen if in
a month's time if my beard still looks
like this they won't
I'm I'm not going to promote your
product
you know I'm not going to promote it
you're going to see the gains trust me
all right we'll see the gains can I just
say you've forgot a lady or old woman
huh
the lady you forgot her
um
yeah you did I know she's kind of a
butcher masculine
sorry go on ladies lady to the mind
right uh the lady to the right is the
now but obviously the Troublemaker
looking for smoke every single day I am
29 20 30 in about two hours my people
look at the irony of that I'm turning 30
on this damn podcast wow see my life oh
are you single I am single and not ready
to mingle
oh so you're you're single one not ready
to mingle yes so you're so you're okay
so you're turning 30 in two hours yes
sorry and I'm actively not looking so
you're hitting the wall in two hours oh
here we go that's it
that's it in the wall I thought the wall
was 27. listen yeah
seven or Twenty Eight no I haven't hit
the wall I'm running from the wall I
don't want no man around me right now I
got big things going in busy I'm really
excited for my wall
but hang on
Auntie Jenny yeah I'm here I'm Auntie
Jenny 54.
in a relationship
of course you are telling how many years
Auntie tell them how many years 32.
wow and and
fun fact
on a good day I can get my legs off my
shoulders
[Laughter]
[Music]
they're not surprised
wow okay so let's get into it into it
um we have a couple of videos to play
um
but before that I wanna
that's one thing being as an older
person
sign language what sign we're gonna get
into that right okay as a matter of fact
uh blessing
could you play the first video to
explain that's going to explain to us
what sign language actually is let's get
into the first video
oh we can't hear
I thought that's going to be these
headphones are not working in sign
language which is an acronym comprising
of the following toxic traits which is
shame insults guilt and a need to be
right against their opponent when they
themselves can't present a cogent
argument based in facts statistics or
logic this debating tactic is called
sign language here we will Define
discuss and give an example of each word
that makes up the acronym Shame Shame
which is defined as a person action or
situation that makes someone feel
ashamed shame can cause someone to feel
inadequate and often leave them with a
painful sense of humiliation or distress
caused by another person's abusive words
for example who hurt you
insult insult is defined as a
disrespectful or scornfully abusive
remark or action criticizing someone is
an easy target especially if they know
how to hurt that person and often attack
the person where they can feel most
vulnerable whether it's bashing
someone's appear appearance
accomplishment nurturing skills
self-worth or financial worth just to
name a few for example you'll hear
things like you're just bitter or you
don't make enough money to be with me
the guilt the definition of guilt is to
make someone feel guilty especially in
order to induce them to do something
making someone feel like they are not
doing what they are hardwired to do is a
highly effective while toxic and
damaging attack that is often used for
example you obviously hate all women
including your mother or you obviously
hate all men including your dad
The Need to Be Right most people have a
need to be right whatever they say they
want it to be true and for other people
to accept it as being true
at the very least they want to avoid
appearing wrong you will often hear
someone refer back to a real or
perceived slight that took place many
years before and may or even may not be
related to the altercation at hand for
example you don't know what you're
talking about because you're just a
simple man or you're not grasping what
I'm trying to tell you because you are
not listening to me
now here's some real live examples of it
so what else you do outside this uh
[Music]
the job
that's what I do I mean I'm working on a
business also
[Music]
you're working on a business yeah I'm
working on a business I'm working on my
business or you trying to get in my
business I mean I'm working on the
business I mean I we may actually make
good money now I get the bills paid I
had to spending but I guess you know
computers don't let the title like fool
you know like you know
so what do you think I got a house and
use another two bedroom or a piece a two
bedroom
[Music]
[Music]
other people trying to
I'm trying to get to know
[Music]
one yeah a whole child
oh I don't understand too many that's
one way to me
absolutely not is that a is that a first
date
but I think we kind of hush get the gist
because doing the show for how long I'm
sure you've seen sign language I've seen
sign language many times and even online
um when I you know post videos or go
into the comment section one of the
major things when it comes to silent
when sign language women say
you're hurt you hurt you who hurt you
who hurt you why are you saying this and
normally it is a rebuttal to factual
information okay
um no not arguably respect your
information they said that to me all the
time as well they said then I was just
bitter look at who hurt you dinner
but if we if we really do break it down
we understand the manosphere in a Red
Bull space when men are speaking about
things like either divorce
right where men get you know shafted in
divorces or you know suicide rates
amongst men or the way in which you know
women treat men in this day and time
with their hopeless Andrea one of the
major rebuttals that I found is that
women say oh who hurt you you're hurt
so my question is
why is that the rebuttal
are you asking me I'm asking you danella
um well I don't usually say that but
usually when you're talking about who
hurts you may be like who's making a
trip like why are you acting up is it
because your bedrooms are doing better
than you making you feel better about
yourself or is it maybe there was a girl
that came into your life one day and
broke your heart is making you add some
type of way towards everybody else I
think that's where it comes from even
though I don't really say that to people
but you've had it though right
you've heard women say that in regards
to men yeah yeah actually I've said it
before still I was gonna say I've heard
you say okay I was about to say I've
heard that say it but why why is that
the rebuttal when they hear
um factual information on Auntie do you
think I think it's just a fight but just
to try and embarrass people or to make
them feel shame rather than that is just
the way it is it's that's the first one
they come back with like who hurt you no
nobody's hurt me this is just the way I
am this is just the way it is this is
just the way I feel why does somebody
have to hurt me for me to express myself
just because I'm a man
I think if it was how many times as a
woman say to another woman who hurt you
see exactly and then more damage than
anybody else the women it's not me then
the ones that get hurt not the men but
the person they say to me is who hurt
you but I've never heard a woman say to
another woman who hurt you
I think there's two sides to that you
know I feel like a lot of the time we
speak from experience or things that
we've been through so if you're
triggered and you're projecting and
having a moment I feel when people say
that but then there is the other side
because I've been in the position before
if someone's saying something that you
feel like you can relate to or you've
done and you're like the Panic is like
oh who hurt you because you know that
maybe you've displayed that behavior or
that thing before but I think there's
two
I think the issue is it's difficult to
be able to separate those who are saying
who hurt you as an robot or because they
have nothing else to say to the facts
that are being presented by the same
time I do feel like we all come from
relative trauma paid experiences so
sometimes our passion can come across
misleading so you might have a fact but
the way in which you're expressing
yourself is like okay
I get that you're passionate about this
but maybe you're not speaking directly
to me you're speaking from a place of
hurt where did that come from but I can
definitely understand why a man will
fall out okay now that I'm speaking
facts of suddenly who hurt you but
generally like why why are you coming
across so aggressive like just you know
the thing is with that I've always said
like
with we're all sitting on this panel
right we've all been hurt to some degree
right all of us have had a heartbreak
right right and both men and women I'm
immune everybody
how's immune to heartbreak but I'm
saying generally a lot of women have had
a heartbreak yeah but when I'm when a
woman speaks
her truth or whatever it is a man's
rebuttal to the woman's argument is not
who hurt you
but a woman's rebuttal to a man's
argument would be who hurt you as
fingers anytime a Man shows a bit of
emotion that they honestly believe that
because he's shown a bit of emotion they
must be showing it just because they've
got hurt now they're doing it because
they've got feelings the other one I get
all that is you're insecure you're
insecure insecure yeah yeah but does
that separate because the thing is you
you can have an opinion and you can also
at the same time seem insecure like
those things can close this at the same
time and I can understand that it's
frustrating when you're trying to have a
conversation that's supposed to be
Progressive that someone only highlights
the insecurity but right ultimately I'm
highlighting what I'm seeing and that's
not immediately a problem
even though it's not immediately
Progressive for that conversation but
the thing is do you hurt you in my
personal experience from what I've
experienced is used to deflect
it's a deflection tactic yeah
to uh to not actually deal with what is
actually being said it's the same thing
with urine secure it's the same thing
with you're insecure yeah then it's like
honestly modern women have like a A
system that they go through yeah it
usually starts with like who hurt you um
then it goes to your insecure then they
might attack something about your looks
or incision and if it's a guy like if to
me they usually go for like my style or
like the way I look something like that
you're white yeah yeah but if they don't
do that if it's a guy they might go for
his money say insinuate he has a small
or like say he can't get girls
yeah sometimes yeah
um and then if that doesn't work they'll
maybe say you need therapy that's a
common one yeah
um smooth energy yeah I've got small
dick energy
there are stereotypes to everything and
again we it's fair to say that these are
all deflections but they are real things
and I think when we're speaking up
specifically women who are you know
thrown out these um these statements
these are people that perhaps are not
used to being in situations where men
can articulate themselves or show an
emotion we're not how do you deal with
that you're probably used to men who
shut down and walk away so now that
you're in a situation where somebody's
actually given you the opportunity to
communicate the only thing you're able
to say is that your Butters anyway
you're like oh your Butters anyways
do you know what I think you're dead
anyways you get it shut Up Bones
actually I actually think women have a
hard time with hearing the truth about
themselves I agree and so when you have
a hard time hearing the truth about
yourself your instant reaction is to
attack back because you feel attacked
yeah and it may not generally be an
attack the most the most I've ever been
attacked is when I said men don't like
fat chicks right I swear to God exactly
and like I'm
like I'm just saying by and large they
don't and she did the Jamaica
[Laughter]
they might like they might like a fat
ass and big boobs but they don't no guy
wants to go they like big bags they like
curvy not fat yeah there's a difference
oh wow but that's the thing it's like
we can't we can't say that we have we
have to kind of differentiate because
like I said like my question is like in
your experience as women
in your the women would you say that
women like to hear the truth about
themselves no no I remember when I used
to be held accountable in my last
relationship which was five years I
stopped crying because I just didn't
know where else the conversation would
go I just didn't want to be held
accountable like I felt like if we're
having a dispute it was like I'm in a
position of power I'm here to tell you
what you did wrong because I I it was
like what do you mean I did something as
well to facilitate this then I'll just
go into my emotional bags for crying
would you they took me a long time to
unlearn that I was like it's okay to
like we can both be wrong and be afford
from a situation would you would you cry
so he would kind of stop coming at you
yeah I feel like you'd feel sorry for me
maybe you'd lower his toe maybe he'll
kind of deal with me with a bit more
like dude he didn't want us he did yeah
[Laughter]
and you realize it as you get older how
you might have behaved growing up and
especially as a child trying to be that
perfect kid or that girl that behaves in
a certain way and then when you get into
relationships and you're not with mummy
and daddy or the people that tell you
that everything you do is right or
whatever and you're like what do you
mean I can't say that what do you mean
like huh you know who also do you know
the people that also do that their
children children yeah yeah
I've said that I've been called a
misogynist right and I've said a lot of
modern women just act like children
they do because like you said and you
admitted to when it was coming a little
bit too close to the Bone and it was
time for you to take accountability you
started crying which is manipulation
because you wanted to manipulate that
that um that scenario to your benefit
exactly right and so a lot of men I feel
like
aren't well versed in the way in which
women communicate part of women's
communication communication strategy is
manipulation I think it is a major part
of women's communication strategy I
think it builds up from your parents if
they stop lying to women my parents
always tell me the truth I was always
called Full Moon because I had a big
round head you know I know the greasy
skin no matter which way the sunshine my
hands always show up so I grew up with
being called big head yeah you know so
people come at me especially when the
podcast they go so I look at that old
woman yeah I know I'm old so that's all
right and I've got a big head to come on
you know what else and my man always
tells me straight you know you're
getting fat you look big you know at
least you grew into your head no I
haven't
[Music]
but I find that growing up as a child
too many you know oh she's so pretty I
told my granddaughter look at your big
head you got a big head just like your
daddy's got a big head your grandma's
got a big head yeah everyone's got a big
head look at you and your big head so
nobody can't insult her because she's
been insulted from Young you got a big
head and nobody can't tell him and I
think sometimes that it's a shock to
women if they get a man that tells them
the truth my man tells me the truth all
the time but people think that he's
being really cruel to me or he's being
horrible and there's how can you just
take that take what the fact that he's
telling me the truth like
are you stupid I said course I am
I I do want to add though because I know
before we started filming briefly I was
saying that men uh communicate from more
of a logical standpoint and I think
another thing that I realized in my
relationship when I was reflecting is
that I wasn't used to such like
bloodness and logic I didn't know how to
handle that and it took me a long time
to understand that
my quote-unquote partner at the time
being straightforward blunt wasn't him
purposely trying to hurt my feelings or
like not showing emotion but again I
think many to also understand that
because we communicate differently we
tend to communicate from emotion so when
you're speaking to me and it comes
across blunt and it's like I'm not
really feeling any emotion I want to
kind of pull that out of you I'm not
intending to manipulate you but I'm just
trying to can we make this we're not in
a board room like I want to feel like
I'm speaking to a human being and
there's nothing there we're from
different planets which is fair is it
many for months
I gotta tell you something and like
low-key you're like oh yeah
it's fine it's cool
but the thing is I always tell men to
not get drawn onto the female
Battlefield nah because you communicate
in a way that we don't right and because
men essentially I know women like to act
like they don't men essentially want to
make women feel the best that we do like
if you're our woman we want to keep you
as happy as we can right but we
understand that you understand that
and so if you understand that we want to
make you happy you might manipulate us
to try and make you happy which will
also which will also feed into the
argument or let's say arguments but the
communication that we have so I've
always said you're saying oh we want you
to show a little bit of emotions once we
do that once you see it once you see a
[ __ ] in their armor you'll try and open
that whole door
so I'm just like as a man I'm just like
no we just we have to be logical and
stoic and straightforward we have to be
because if I've noticed that if a lot of
women feel like
there's a [ __ ] in a Man's armor they'll
exploit it you know what I found the
best thing to do is make your point walk
away leave this scenario and just let it
marinate because because women like it
takes a while for the information to
sink in yeah it takes like a couple days
at worst and then you'll realize oh [ __ ]
he was right and then she cries walk
away and leave her
there because women I just think that if
a woman cries in front of a man it's
manipulation otherwise just go in your
bedroom and cry on your own wipe your
tears and come back but if you're crying
in front of if you're crying in front of
a man it's pure manipulation do you
think women manipulate with crying I'm
just taking this all in to be honest
with you so so I think firstly
manipulation comes from somebody not
feeling secure or safe in a situation so
like the word manipulation has been
utilized in so many different forms but
actually understanding why the human
brain and behavior does that everything
comes from childhood so again like you
said like if your mum was extremely
manipulative and you've watched her
utilize emotion as a way to get what she
wants in the situation then that's going
to be something that's adopted within
you whether you're male or female
regardless was that the question yeah
but do you do as a woman do you feel
like or if you look back on whether it
be now or past do you feel like you've
manipulated the situation yeah emotion I
had a massive breakdown like five years
ago and I discovered that I had a
subconscious for the first time and I
didn't realize that my subconscious has
been playing out without my awareness of
it and on reflection of that
relationship but I literally I I become
like the most manipulative person ever
because I didn't feel safe I didn't know
what was going on I didn't feel safe in
my brain in my own body in my own house
and like that took me a long I actually
tried to commit suicide over actually
having to accept that that was a part of
me at that moment in time and actually
come back with a lot of compassion and
understand as to why I did that and
again like speaking to my boyfriend
after the apologies are coming out of me
of actually being like Oh my God that
was a part of me I hated that part of me
so much
um so yeah it was not a fun it was not a
fun point in life
glad you came through it yeah it
highlighted to me also that like
my response to having to ignore
acknowledge my own bad behavior was to
then make myself and again which in
itself was like a really good tell to be
able to walk through life and understand
not necessarily just women but when
people are put in a position of having
to accept responsibility for their
behavior it becomes a narrative again
and every story needs a victim of a
villain and not many people want to play
the villain in the story so they sit in
the victim and I've noticed that women
are very good victims women are great
storytellers yeah yeah women a woman
will tell you a story and she's never
ever the aggressor in the story She's
Always a victim no admin it's always a
crazy exactly it's over you no I've been
doing this show four days a week talking
about relationships for months I've
men don't ever say crazy ex women talk
about their narcissistic acts
like he was a narcissist it's like one
percent it's less than one percent of
the population but every modern woman
thinks she's dated one yeah everyone
said no part to play he was just a
narcissist it's like it takes two to
tango if you're in a toxic relationship
you're toxic too there's a chemical
reaction isn't it so it's how two of
your interacting with each other
I just really that women need to just
stop thinking with this not being
emotional just a bit logically it's so
much easier the world is an easier place
if it doesn't speak logically how do you
think women just attend to this if it
don't sound like common sense and you
can't prove it it's your feelings and
your feelings don't count in the real
world keep them to yourself because if
you I can go out there and I can talk to
any man because I've been brought up
thinking logically I don't think of my
emotions if I'm going to get emotional I
get quite embarrassed I go in my room
and shut down get have an emotional 10
minutes and come back out all right
because that's it there's a lady who
might Teach an episode of wife's school
who is telling me like one thing she
teach like she um she's been a housewife
for like 30 years she's married to like
a high value guy and she she does um
she's like a kick-ass housewife like she
makes all the food from scratch Gardens
like she does she says about me yeah she
does perfect she does freaking
everything and she was saying how she
teaches her girls your feelings
literally don't matter like they they
literally they do I'm not sure and my
mom always taught me growing up to wait
like if you're mad about something to
wait two days and if you're still mad
then you can say something but usually
if you wait the two days you don't even
care yeah
I'm angry yeah don't do anything angry
oh sorry Auntie I'm gonna say I have I
am definitely I have I have it's
interesting because I've been listening
to what everybody has been saying I've
been kind of putting it on me and
thinking how do I act I think my problem
as a woman we're saying all of this
women need to be more logical and common
sense I think I'm way too
straightforward as a woman and that gets
me to some seriously common sense as
well yeah you're saying the two don't
don't go together when it comes to you
sometimes of course they did just not
from your side no
no I'll tell you how it makes sense
because you said you were prettier than
Rihanna before
I hate they said to me oh how well do
you look like Rihanna or something I was
like actually I get Colvin all the time
and if I had the money yeah she's gone
I'll be better than her Ariana from wish
though
like a budget Rihanna oh well
she's a billionaire blood like well I'm
not gonna try and fight against a
billionaire I know my level but I'm
leveling up do you but you said yeah
that's what I mean do you know that's
what I mean about thinking logically and
with common sense look I'll be logical I
know as a woman what I represent and why
actually I give myself an 8.5 and it
goes in so many ways oh my God it's 8.5
I was giving you eight oh shoot no yes
8.5 the famous the famous phrase is
maybe in London but you should see the
girls in California not in London in
London yeah take me anywhere
you know you know that's what they say
say about no offense guys they say in
London like you get one to two points
deducted
or deducted yeah
it's the same thing in the midwest in
the US like you it's like the mid yeah
it's like the same thing I'm very
confident but it's like if you go to I'm
talking about like LA and Miami are like
that is the most beautiful women I have
ever seen in my life and it's like you
might think yourself and then go to LA
in Miami you will be humbled do you know
why do you know why I must be beautiful
woman I saw in my life were in South
Africa and East Africa yeah yeah
South Africa well I'm Southern African
I'm Mongolian so I'm close
I don't need more gas I wanted to say
girl thank you Sarah for setting me up I
wanted to add that we do have to be very
careful when you talk about the
importance of
um speaking from a place of logic and
not immediately advocating for emotional
Detachment because
your your feelings are valid you just
don't have to always walk in them and
express them I think you have to be able
to separate the two and whilst we're
speaking about communication Styles I do
feel like a lot of men do practice
emotional
um Detachment in in in situations with
women with the whole like keep them mean
keep them Keen kind of like attitude and
it might not be intentional but they
know that it's equally as effective as
for example a woman crying if I know
that emotionally Detachment situation
she's probably going to that later on to
me a bit more so I just don't think your
feelings are always valid like I think
sometimes your feelings are stupid no
they could be no they can be stupid cry
over the dumbest like the like or you
know how it is like when before your
period yeah and you'll you'll look back
like a couple days later and you're like
what was I doing no okay but in the in
the future perhaps then but in that
present moment you cried for a reason it
was a real feeling I'm not saying that
they're important I'm just saying that
there was a real thing and you're
allowed to feel things have you have you
ever have you ever like Pearl was saying
have you ever cried up something that
you looked back on and said what that
why why was I even crying absolutely
right okay so men generally okay right
if a man cries it's because of something
men don't cry over oh my God I went to
the restaurant today or went to the
coffee shop saying I never had my
favorite croissant and I was on my
period and so I was like oh my God
guys don't do that right but what I'm
trying to say dogs don't do that yes yes
I don't behave like that my period is
three days clean quick don't get
emotional don't get paid I've been a cry
for no reason I don't like to cry I like
to talk straight in logic facts anyway
the point I'm making is that if you know
as a woman you've looked back on
times that you've cried and been
emotional right and known that maybe I
was overreacting a little bit maybe I
was hormonal maybe I was on my period
right and we know as men that we
generally don't do that when when
as men
when it comes to communication when do
we take you seriously
now honest question like when if if we
know that women can cry over that kind
of stuff okay if a woman comes to us
crying when when do we take you
seriously two days after the emotional
breakdown
we kind of look to men to like deciphers
yeah like how curious is this yeah
because I feel like men should go off of
their because you guys are more
naturally logical than us like I feel
like you should not ask a woman when to
take you some seriously because a girl
wants to manipulate them
the reason why I asked that is because
women always say oh I know my period but
if we say
shut up
if we say oh just chill out man it's not
that you're not taking me seriously so
all right so if I'm not taking seriously
now when you're on your period when do I
take you seriously when you're off your
period remember to me
three days before your period three days
after your break when do we take it you
sound so logical like maybe I just need
a hug well you don't need to have to
like rationalize this whole situation
and we don't actually want guys to fix
the problem no I guess when you behave
me and I don't know
figure it out I just want us to make you
feel better in the moment
you can't ask me what do I want because
I don't know
it's hard to do that when you're in the
wrong though you know what I mean I want
to ask girls how many guy friends do you
have like brethrens how many do you have
do you have a lot because I'm not gonna
lie if you have a lot of guys around you
that your graduates they'll tell you
shut up no not ready
I get a lot of princess treatment for my
friends my brothers
your guy friends are trying to sleep
with you
okay so so do you do you have a guy
friend who wouldn't
yes can you call him girl oh my God
call Ali Ali
what's your what's your name
cheers
do you know do you know how you can get
candles okay no no I'm saying like like
could you use my phone
my phone so ladies are you literally you
really believe that your guy friends
quote unquote guy friends that if you
called them up at like 12 midnight
and said oh you know what I've always
kind of thought about
something could have happened between us
come round right now
hell no yeah any woman who generally
feels like girls and guys can be friends
is naive actually
circumstances under some sort of
influence you understand that no
nine times out of ten they were my close
guy friends are queer I'll be like they
know they're gay and that's why it works
because they're not looking for me
they're like they're not looking for me
outside of that I've had to change I
felt like oh no that's my brew and then
it's not it's not my record right
exactly it's an equivocation to think
that men and women cannot have platonic
friendships
they can't only be only when women
create those boundaries
if you like girls can be quote unquote
or women can be friends with men but men
can't immediately be friends because
given the opportunity he would bang so
you are creating the parameter listen
like whatever the case I just know that
still means he wants to [ __ ] you right
exactly
no not really that's not even the case
my friendships with my friends the way
they've started were very natural it
wasn't anything about sexual we always
started with a very deep conversation
about real stuff so they understood the
kind of woman that I am and they put the
sexuality aside why because they
respected the way they approach them and
they respect everything
[Laughter]
I wonder if they're still your friend oh
yeah of course they will okay listen
I've gone up and down with these friends
and they're always there they because
they're like 150 pounds oh no I don't
even know how much let me let me flesh
it out you see when they say friends
right my brethrens your your bridgens
are you telling me that you've been
alone with these guys
ah an interesting hour of the Night
Under the Influence I'm gonna Implement
and and no one's done anything
definitely oh my God even now like
sometimes even yesterday one of my
brothers was around I was at home I
finished my Bros yeah and I said I even
had yo bro
we hang out we talk about uh business
plans to talk about what we are on
projects we plan
um I cook for them because I like to
cook for people we hang out with
children bed with them yes and and
obviously I don't have to because they
will live there I've shared bed with my
friends you know what it is and they
don't even touch me
homosexual
you know what it is
exactly they're just waiting on standby
in it like no if you stuck it on them
then they would go with the food 100
million percent they will go with the
flow if you stuck it on them because
you're not sticking it on them they're
just like oh just I'll just stay in my
legs I stay in my Lane I'm not gonna
overstep I heard I heard you can tell me
if this is true I heard that guys are
friends with girls because they know at
some point the girls will [ __ ] their
friends if they wait around long enough
yeah the whole friend zone
the men in friend zones are very
successful like you just I've always
said it's like I'm curious all right
raise your hand like got the girls here
raise your hand if you've had a guy make
it out of the friend zone
no one see that make it out yeah make it
out I have I have really yeah I have but
I'm hoping that my best but then why was
he in that episode
for a man I need to understand why was
he in the friend zone and what was it
what was it that made him out that made
him be able to get out of the friend
zone
um he was in the friend zone because
we
he was just a bit too
much of a little bit too
like I just felt like he wouldn't like
commit if I ever went there because he
was just yeah but then we were friends
for like a couple years and so and so we
became less of a hoe
um yeah he kind of settled down like he
wasn't as wild as he like used to be
okay okay and then
huh and then then and then they weren't
friends anymore what happened what do
you do this makes you realize women are
always in control of sex
women are always in control of sex when
it comes to like that like men are never
in control of sexual situations if a
woman can keep you on standby for two
years
friends for decades actually friends my
guy friends from high school
you really want to prove this the ones
now you're about to hit 30. you might
start looking in the face
funny I did say this I said listen these
people be trying to talk and say that I
can't find a man and I'm going to be
stuck and hit a wall worst case I will
have a best friend I'll give me a baby
oh my goodness
so if you can take your guy out the
friend zone
for the right one now no no no no but
it's because rewind back to your point
okay
basically what I want now is I'm tired
of having to think about committing to
somebody for the rest of my life that
I'm not quite sure about and I don't
know so I'll just say I'll pick the with
somebody that is genetically nice and
fit you'll become my best friend we'll
hang out if you're really cool enough
we'll have a baby we take care of the
baby but there's not much more to it
that's it
no that's because I'm changing my mind
you sound like a man
don't think that's selfish
to be to be voluntarily be and bring up
a kid and where their parents aren't
together to do that like on purpose
because love it's like love doesn't mean
that you have to kiss each other and be
like oh my God you're my husband and my
wife love comes in so many different
shapes and forming I think that was
healthy is for a child to have love and
to be able to understand that they have
two parents that love them they care for
them
what would wait wait wait can I just say
one thing what would be better what
would be better
um a kid that has a parent in two
different homes or a kid that is a
parent in both homes well if the parent
both homes and getting along you'd
rather have them in different homes
I just want to healthy parents I'm
saying this is before there's not even
fighting yet I'm saying like you're
picking this so before the kids even
like you're not even giving the the real
thing a shot so okay I'll say it but
because I I talk about myself right
everything that it says based on my own
experience right you talk about yourself
obviously uh there's only one to novice
you don't I'm enough but I would
definitely say for me I feel like I'm
healthier having a good balance of my
own space and Independence and having
somebody that I can also spend some time
with in company but realistically at
this point looking at how things are
going having these conversations I
realized that you know
um unconditional forever love in
marriage it seems a bit bogus
can I just say something
um I need to so I'm gonna get a sign
here I can press the button I want a
[ __ ] sign you love it because you're
talking pure [ __ ] you just sat
around and said that no no this is my
point of view from what you said right
men can't men and women can be friends
right you've got male friends and not
going to come at the friend zone they're
going to stay in the friend zone because
that's the way you are but if by chance
now that you decide that you're getting
old and that you want a child you're
gonna hand pick the best meal out of all
of your friends to have a child with
than to separate that's selfish [ __ ]
because now you're never understand that
that is selfish [ __ ] because you're
not even thinking about the child you're
just being selfish you are go you might
as well go to one of them sperm banks
and get a child from a sperm bank or get
IVF because you're going out there and
you're deliberately choosing to put a
child I'm not a step person at a
disadvantage as a single person on
purpose am I that
isn't it
she didn't say anything about single
parents
let me finish she just said right you
can rewind it later on she just said
that she will go out there she will get
one of her friends she will have a child
because she don't believe in all this
happy relationship love forever after
that she will have a child with one of
the men that she is hand-picked one of
her friends and then she will separate
recipe that genetically fit man but
you're gonna be an old dog by then and
nobody's going
you're saying you've got five years but
has your body got five years because
you're not a biologist and you can't
tell I know she just said that she was
gonna go out there and she that is why
Pearl asked you isn't that selfish or
why are you going out there and
deliberately deciding to have a child as
a single parent what would you like that
I'd rather have you stretch your legs I
don't have no children if you can't be
in a healthy relationship will a man and
woman together getting on well to raise
a child together and you're deliberately
going out there and choosing to have a
child as a single parents
what do you say because what I said is I
would rather have a child with two
parents in separate homes than to have
them under one home in a toxic situation
you said but I'm saying you didn't even
try to have the relationship with the
friend because
that's the whole that's Handy's full
Point yeah is you're picking listen
listen okay you're picking to be a
single parent without even trying no
it's one thing it's one thing okay to be
in love and then you guys can't work it
out and then later I mean I still think
you should work it out that that's a
whole nother conversation but that's
that's a separate situation then going
in and saying you know what I don't
think I can get along with a man so but
because I want a kid I'm gonna raise him
in a situation where they're they're in
two separate houses which we know which
we know isn't good for the kids okay
because otherwise it's going to be toxic
like why why is it it's going to be a
toxic situation
why can't it just be that you try to get
along with the guy friend it's the same
thing that Nick Cannon is doing in it
he's having babies
let me finish let me finish all right
let me land let me land Let Me Lie what
I'm saying is at the end of the day Nick
Cannon understood that the most
important thing is not the fact that the
parents need to be together is how much
you can provide for the child and that's
why I said I want somebody to get on
with so that actually when I do have a
kid it's co-parenting in the healthiest
of ways you want to be a sister wife
is that what you call them yeah like if
you if there's a man who's a who's a
high value Alpha man and he breeds I
don't know six seven women you want to
be one of you want to be no a man who's
a concubine it's a woman who's a
concubine to a very high value I'm
explaining okay
because he's a parent that is not
present in everything
and he's probably not a good father
because how are you possible how are you
possibly a good present father for all
of those six children when you're not
impressed okay now that's hone it into
on to my example I'm not saying that I'm
going to be with a man that has a
million children I can have all of his
kids it's okay and what we do is we
together as people we now know that
we've come together to bring life and to
make sure that that life grows healthily
it's not about me and you because
normally the issues that people have is
that they make about their relationship
and then who suffers in the kids
let me just get this straight okay I
just wanna I just want to clarify you
think the best situation for a kid is to
find a friend and then raise that kid in
two separate homes rather rather than
maybe find a friend and think hmm maybe
I can make this guy my husband and learn
to get along with a man
and and raise the kid under a house with
two parents and not make it toxic and
make make it your mission to have a
happy healthy home so I I listen I've
got to this point of understanding what
I actually need in my life and I
understand that I need space because I
don't have the mental capacity to have
to trust somebody who I don't know the
ins and outs people you don't have the
mental capacity
you go into things with fear yeah
there's no future yeah so so it's like
if you constantly
your future husband you know but like if
you're constantly thinking what's the
worst thing that can happen it's going
to be toxic like a good man who would
treat you right is going to be scared
off because he's getting this girl
that's saying well I don't know every
part of you how can I trust you and and
so the guy that actually would treat you
right and be a good dad is going to be
scared off by that okay and another
thing as well this is one of the reasons
why I've always said to men right don't
listen to what women say watch what they
do there's a difference okay it's
because this woman then Alva will come
on the show and say yeah but you know
it's a friend's own man's not coming out
he's not coming out the friend zone
what's she gonna do 10 years later and
another thing what women do can I just
not listening
I want to add something quickly um I
feel like we go we are going into these
situations with these high expectations
of I need to know somebody 100 you're
never going to know somebody's ins and
out 100 we don't even know ourselves 100
like the process of like the
individuation process We Are Forever
Learning people are forever changing so
that fear of like I can't go into the
situation and not trust somebody just
get rid of that okay I know you're
trying to safeguard yourself and I
understand when you first said about the
fact that you know traditional
companionship is a bit dated in this
modern day but it's possible so like
just don't don't like okay I understand
that but let me tell you something yeah
the more I open my eyes up to the world
around me is the more that I understand
everybody is quite messed up in their
own way yeah but you always still feel
pain
but I would rather feel pain where I can
actually deal with it better than to
have to feel pain from someone else
Whose actions
the last thing she said was from
somebody she can't control yeah that is
your problem no who's the actions I
can't control anymore
you need to control yourself listen and
I do and that's why I said I would
rather be in a situation where I can
control myself and not have to be audio
why wouldn't you just not have if you
want to make life about you and what you
want don't have kids but it's not about
one of me and what I want I know that's
what I'm saying it is
wait okay if you if you're putting your
feelings above the kid so if you're
saying you know because I don't want to
get along with a man that I can't
control his actions your words your
words okay so so because you're putting
your feelings above what's best for a
child so if that's what you want to do
then why would you have a child okay
I'll repeat exactly what I said again as
a woman I am very nurturing and I'll be
a great a great mother I know that
listen I don't need anyone to to tell me
this or not because none of you actually
know me in my private life in my
personal life which means never yes wait
wait no you don't actually you don't you
actually don't you know you actually
don't you really don't know what I do on
a daily basis and that's what I say for
me what I am thinking of the child
because I would rather have a very
healthy relationship with somebody that
have a child with that is not based on
possession or having to try and get on I
don't want to have to do that because
the friction is going to go on the kids
so instead my main focus will be on
keeping myself happy so I can give the
best that I am to my child
but does that child need two parents
yeah and they'll have two parents oh I'm
not going to take the child away do you
understand and the thing is we've spoken
about this on the show on multiple
occasions that you put your child at
every statistical disadvantage when you
choose to become a single mother I'm
choosing to become a single one now hang
on but you're choosing to have to raise
a child in a household without a man
okay so your child is more likely to be
homeless your child is more likely to go
to prison your child is more likely to
have mental issues your child is more
likely to be a an angry Grapist he's
more likely to be in a gang she he or
she no wait hang on can children that
come from single parent households
specifically single mother households
are subject to all of those things okay
and it can range from 60 of the children
you need more detail to my story then to
Absolute the children
like the fact that you would choose that
kind of shows can I just say something
right because I like to go by what I
know I don't know about stats and all
that this man here
was in a relationship thought they'd be
forever it got messed up he's not
co-parenting would he have chose to be a
co-parent in the beginning no no you're
going out there and you're choosing the
only reason why he's co-parenting
because he knows that my co-parenting
with his child's mother will put his
child at an advantage but otherwise as
they're doing what you're doing you're
putting your child at a disadvantage but
this is a guy that's been there done it
got the t-shirt and you still won't
listen selfies so previous instead of
instead of fully and fully for the Trap
like he did of going through somebody
that you didn't get on in the end they
know your comparing to probably having
friction
wait wait let me land I would rather go
from the beginning and say okay we're
gonna have a baby it's like yeah girl
we're gonna have a baby we have the baby
[ __ ] and you go to your side I go to my
side and we go parents
the woman is the one that stays with the
baby anyway that's wrong because women
like you
and this is why I said somebody that is
a good friend to me somebody that's
because there's a respect I will never
take somebody and my child away from
from a parent from his father you're
doing that no I'm not let me do it no
because you keep shouting instead of
trying to do this now I'm trying again
you've been explaining for ages and ages
and ages it don't make no sense you're
not listening but you want everyone to
listen to you you've got him there
telling you the women they're telling
you yeah
listen you're not saying what I'm saying
you're choosing to try and shout out
rather than just spend the time healing
yourself so you can go into relationship
potentially with a friend and actually
allow yourself to learn how to be loved
How To Love Yourself
baby you're just going to be passing the
same trauma pattern that was probably
possible
onto your child
abundance let me tell you something
you'd rather not be with anyone
can we just rewind before this got mad
deep yeah yes you made this whole point
about our guys that you've got that are
friends that in the friend zone yeah and
they don't move out the friend zone
because they're your friends they will
never step out but this whole argument
started because you said
when you decide to have a kid you'll
just pick one at the friend zone so you
contradict yourself straight away okay
I'll explain myself let's go again so
let me explain your contradiction
explain the contradiction what I want my
ideal situation is to have a man that I
meet with respect each other Beyond
really well we have a love for one
another is there anyone in your friend
zone now no no no no no this is gonna be
somebody new because obviously if that
was the case I would have done it by now
so anyway I'm actually fall in love with
them
that's more unrealistic though in your
dreams
you asked me to explain it every time I
say something you just interrupt that's
why you don't get the point so the point
is some if you have respect for somebody
so for example if I have if I'm with a
guy that we respect each other but we
don't have to be in a possessive
relationship where it's like you're mine
and I'm yours no I want it to be a case
of for example we have a baby and every
single day we communicate you can come
over my house I can come over to yours
the baby will grow daddy lives there
Mommy lives here you can go to Daddy's
house
you've got a better chance grabbing one
of the guys in the friend zone and
having a kid with him because you know
them you're friends with them and having
a relationship listen you've got
literally probably zero percent chance
meeting a guy fresh and being like hey I
know you just met but let's have a kid
that's Dreamland
right 90 of single mother of single
parent households are headed by mothers
90 of them yes single parent households
are headed by mothers right 63 of Youth
suicides are from single mother homes
ninety percent of homeless and runaway
children are from single mother homes 71
of high school dropouts are from single
mother homes okay 70 of use in operated
institutions are from single mother
homes eighty percent of use in prison
are from single mother homes 80 five
percent of children who show behavioral
disorders are from single mother homes
and eighty percent of children with
anger issues are from single mother
homes
you're saying you want to be a single
mother essentially when and if I read
you these stats and what it's going to
be like for your child generally you
might be
the you might hang on to say oh but it
says 80 which means I might be on the 20
I'm an exception you haven't accepted to
the rule but the rule looks like this
because I wouldn't be
I wouldn't answer yes
or no I wouldn't be yes or no you
wouldn't be a single person only that
I'll ask you again how do you feel about
putting your children in that situation
since you're not with the mom but like I
wasn't gonna buy a toy
I'm not I never chose to be a single
father
communication this is what we're talking
about communication right you I we spoke
about at the beginning of the show I
showed you statistics your rebuttal to
me was to use an emotional response to
say oh but you put your child in that
situation yeah but you know what I never
because I did not choose to be a single
father single fatherhood came to me you
the difference between you and I you are
choosing to put yourself at a
statistical design by putting yourself
in a single mother situation I know what
you are but the thing is you said that
but you said that though
I think the question is
her not being a single moment
that's what she says
listen but that's okay it doesn't need
to be living with me that's the whole
point that's the point he's trying to
make that's what he says because the
father wouldn't be present 24 7 in the
house with you he wouldn't listen to you
and you're saying and you even said that
he would come to yours and he would go
back to there so at what point would you
be together okay okay so let me tell you
before women that have men that travel a
lot for business and do this
then yeah
that was me my dad traveled for business
and it absolutely I was not in a single
parent home there you go there no I
that's what I'm saying because your dad
is still present even though he's not
there physically no but that's that's
why no no no no it's not the same thing
because I knew my mom and my dad were in
love and when I and I got to see my
parents be in love growing up and even
when all my friends came over and they
were they were both together they'd
always say your parents get along better
than all the other parents and I got to
grow up seeing my parents in love I got
to see them go on dates when I was a kid
I got to where I remember we would like
cook for them and do like a date night
and like surprise them and we have these
family memories we're at Christmas like
we all do the same Christmas stockings
we have family traditions that we do
every year you don't get that in a
single mother home
why did I say bestie because we get on
we hang out yeah
the main issue is attention the
intention to not be in a relationship no
one's disregarding how you feel about
what you want to want to do but you're
the arrangement that you have in your
head so that's it yeah that's it you
don't be in a relationship
S
I don't want to belong to somebody
like where is the obsession with
possessions
this is straight cut is that not you
wanted to possess them you want to
control them I don't it all comes down
from everything that we talk about on
these shows I have another conclusion
that actually men do like a woman to be
seen men like to be like oh
there are so many different
relationships
do you know how many years
one of your best friends are sims just
go and grab one of them
say something you're painting this
picture does not take away from the fact
that you're actually in a relationship
there's gonna be Rules of Engagement
yeah you are already in a relationship
so whatever you think you're running
away from you've already created they're
just trying to make it sound like it's
not that exactly and that's why but
that's you're lying to yourself
listen did I not just say somebody that
is like my bestie summer that we hang
out very well because we do have a
relationship he's not not just a
traditional relationship why would you
know any of them already because I don't
want to be want to beat somebody I don't
want to have to live the seafood in love
with them well maybe if if you're not
letting yourself fool okay
it's like you want the family but you
don't want the responsibility
you want to be like you want to do
family on easy mode I think I
have just gone to
two six of life like the whole thing of
family this decides no we're here to
survive we're here for survival I'm
thriving
tomorrow you could die like you know why
would you be living on Survival yes
I want to have children not because I
want to have all my me and my husband
I'm done with the ideal family it
doesn't work anymore people don't think
like that until you go ahead people
don't think like that no that's why
you're fighting so much no no no that's
what you don't think like that everybody
else does anyway so when she was talking
about when you were saying oh that was
your father working she was like yeah
your father's he was always away and he
was always there how many homes did your
father where did he live he traveled all
the time for what but when he came home
where was home so she can't say that
because we live in separate houses that
is the same as your dad being absent
being at work because he came home yeah
she has a man and they have separate the
man could never call where his child is
home because the child's gonna have two
separate arms so it's not the same as
your father being away because your
father knew where home was he always
came home and he knows it's in his home
you can have we can be my neighbor if
you want like just don't live in my
house I don't want that I think I'm just
tired
well then didn't you guys say that women
should be more logic there we go
if it was logical she would have thought
about it she would have thought about
the pros and cons of the child she would
have listened to the stats and then she
would have thought about the child about
the child so you're not thinking
logically because a man if a man's
thinking logically he wouldn't be he
wouldn't be thinking well let me do this
and let me do that logically we're
thinking this is what's going to happen
to my child well it's like 80 of this is
happening to the child and this is what
I'll be thinking about the child it's
not not logical it is
why most men tend to stay in a
relationship because they think about
the practicality or being present women
tend to be the first to want divorce
wait wait wait how is it that us living
in several houses means he's not
presents
okay okay let's talk someone who's done
it let's talk to someone
wait wait wait wait
um Sarah you you went from being in a
relationship yeah to now you co-parent
yes is it the same no tell me about the
differences it's not the same even
though right now you it's successful
peaceful roughly co-parent right so tell
me tell me about the differences the the
child is a child when they wake up in
the morning and they see both parents in
the house and then they come home
from school and they see both parents in
the house they and if they get used to
that um Dynamic right when that is
removed from them there is a schism
that they have to go through within
their own mind and it happened with my
child oh I won't like happen with him he
had to get used to going to Daddy's
house and Mommy's house right he's used
to Mommy and Daddy being together right
so you've now got to explain to that
child oh you know what
um daddy's not there because so and so
and so and so and we still you know
we're still cool with your mom and dad
but the thing is what happens is they
get children are not stupid people think
children are stupid you guys have all
been children we've all been children we
know we've picked up on certain things
when it comes to our parents and we've
been like okay children pick up on
things okay you are in in my personal
point of view de Nava you are very
selfish okay you're thinking about
yourself you're not thinking about
children you're not thinking about the
idol situation for children the ideal
situation for any child and even as a
child yourself you know that it would be
being in a household with both mom and
dad even even a pearl situation Dad
wasn't there all the time the child
knows in the back of their mind this is
still Daddy's house this is still where
Dad lives dad doesn't live outside the
house he he works outside the house but
he still lives here with Mom Dad and the
rest of us Maya highlight some key
difference your situation came through
togetherness and separation if you're
not together from the beginning the
conversation is different secondly
secondly secondly when we are then
talking about it's not an adult
situation yeah no for a child I'm saying
not for you it would be
I will explain to you why because Mommy
and Daddy love each other Mommy and
Daddy they may live in separate houses
if I see Daddy all the time and every
time they're together they smile because
they're giving themselves the space
because they respect each other and
their main goal together their
relationship is based on making sure
that I am okay as a child which means
daddy takes care of me Mommy
say something
you've created a whole scenario that
doesn't even exist
you literally just created a scenario
you've created a fictional scenario that
in your head right exists and make sense
no no but it's not dreams because
children children are not subject to
your dreams children are subject to the
environment and the situation that they
are in
them
kids aren't stupid it crazy and one day
kids notice if their mother is selfish
and the question is if they know one day
that you chose to put them at every
statistical disadvantage and I've talked
to to kids where their parents are
separate I actually my my mom um her
parents were separated they were like
lived in separate houses and it's not
fun and and some of some of the some of
the kids were really mad at the parents
for doing that yeah
the kids
wait wait kids aren't stupid one day
they grow up and they notice that their
mother is selfish and the question is do
they forgive you for being selfish no
they don't listen um
people are going to say I'm triggered
you know what because
I am triggered one thing that you forgot
to mention Sarah is that
not only does the child have to get used
to the two parents living in different
houses that child's no longer special at
school
that child now has to explain to his
friends while it has to go there at a
weekend and while it has to go there and
I've met selfish women like you and when
they're talking about suicide because
you might think it's funny but I've met
a woman like you and her son threw
himself onto a train I love that kid
dearly because of selfish people because
that's exactly what you wanted to do go
and find a friend that she got on with
have a child for a friend that weren't
going to be together and so they can it
[ __ ] up the children's heads
don't no it was like you oh we're really
good friends we're gonna have a child
together and we're gonna call parents it
don't work it messes up what the
children said so you've been there for
them think that you know it all right
because you're going to be the exception
they don't work man out there and you
see her don't [ __ ] her boy
because it is like kind of half time I
mean you do need to read the super chats
bro
you haven't said much yeah
I feel like you're you probably maybe
you've experienced or seen situations
that haven't been successful because
it's Auntie Jenny you've been really
married for 32 years oh okay in a
relationship for 32 years and even that
that is
like that's a serious commitment and
maybe you don't you don't see like the
positives out of that situation because
there are parents that do love each
other fall in love and then
unfortunately they stay in the situation
because of their children that's also an
unhealthy situation even if they are
living in the same house so I think
maybe that's where your angle but that's
not always the way that it's gonna go
and I think it's about the person that
you choose yeah to be within the person
I mean it's true but then if we're going
to base everything
yeah yeah yeah okay we're gonna we're
gonna I hope you guys stayed well and
okay okay
um bring the batowski uh sickness Mr
missing 44. it's a
wait hold on it's a sickness it is
deviant and we don't want it um MVP
danelva that's a super friend with
benefits men don't want that see
Dumbledore's um danelva literally
gaslights herself and believes it too
let's start a good fun GoFundMe for uh
hysterectomy
wow really miss gaming send the asteroid
this generation is doomed um Carm from
the TMR radio people don't think like
that woman I am a millennial and have
been married 14 years three kids same
rational people who want the best for
their children think this way admit it
you were hurt and move on therapy Rob as
a sign language as a therapist who
specializes in trauma go to therapy
please sign language no I think that's
just a professional opinion
um uh d-k-y every time denalva opens her
mouth she proves it she proves she's a
mistake just me me what makes her think
she can be a good mother I don't know if
I need you to stop till the Super chats
are done
um what makes her think she can be a
good mother being so selfish Ryan they
really think um the the NABA is really
enjoying all of the attention and wants
to keep this going
um cam from TMR radio Kevin Samuels
talks about this extensively fear and
lactanel that is using fear to dictate
her actions instead of learning to get
along with a man she will make herself a
single mother Madness Mr missing who
hurt you Queen Goku and Hellcat I wonder
how danelva is when she's home alone and
no with no one's energies to dream she
is sign language
um what ryda Mariah is asking Nick
Cannon to be more present in his twins
lives the truth will set you free
Auntie's the OG like always absolutely
destroyed that deluded angolian woman
worse than Sarah destroyed Muhammad
hijab
um see Dumbledore is I don't get it see
Dumbledore is danelva then is denelva
the Nigerian word for loud delusional
happy
um oh Harpy I didn't do it at pearly not
only are you beautiful but you were the
perfect hype as well as I'd marry you
you have the most amazing and healthiest
gums I've ever seen protect Pearl uh see
Dumbledore whenever I hear a woman claim
she's strong and independent I think of
the quote Margaret Thatcher being
powerful as like being a lady if you
have to tell people you are you aren't
um job hiyo I'm from mid-usa tons go on
vacation to the coast and turn into a
four to six to get the reality check
Cali and Florida women have to stay
beach body ready that's true that's true
um see Dumbledore you get humbled real
quick in Miami I swear to God see
Dumbledore who told women that
confidence in a woman is attractive
women manifest confidence as arrogance
and is extremely unattractive Joe Poe
Sarah auntie and pearl equals guaranteed
good show Doug MPA when men win
everyone's wins when women win women win
the difference in communication Styles
women argue to in for themselves all the
time how is Cheryl
denalva is Shara from Portugal because
she needs a helper classes school
teacher art Warrior space and
organization handles math whiz because
the Bible is a puzzle his classes math
Finance competitive thinks betting
upholding standards poet he is a walking
lie detector
um a Zoe Lost is single women in their
late 20s and have been lied to by
feminism and they have become the
masculine independent man they've always
wanted to marry Aussie Cowboy thanks for
your channel I was blind towards women's
rubbish for a long time I just had I
just had being in the friend zone with
my daughter's mother Edgar Rice she's
old okay that's it
oh my mind
yeah oh there we go
um yeah blessing let's get to the second
video as a matter of fact
um we're gonna play a little video I'm
gonna get your uh you didn't know that
was best sign language too
um anyway we're gonna get second video
just play it let us hear it when you're
ready
put
their hand on a store make it burn okay
respect me back she's not asking you I I
I'll let you answer and when you answer
me no it's just funny because because
like like any time you say something
that's like true or like doesn't put
women in the best light right you say
something that reveals something about
female nature the female knee reaction
is always ask to convert you so it's
always who hurts you but like if you
were to if you you know if you were to
tell me your standards hey I want a guy
that makes money or whatever or guys
taller I'm never gonna look at you and
be like Oh hurt you you can't make your
own money [ __ ] I'm not gonna say that
I'm just like okay that's her standards
that's what she wants whatever guy says
son along with the lines up yeah I don't
really like when a girl does this [ __ ]
[ __ ] or that's some whole [ __ ] oh who
hurt you no it's I have standards too
it's just that female standards or
standards male standards are you know
discrimination
cool the problem is
um thank you blessing
are men question are men allowed to have
standards
of course
um now I'm gonna ask a man I'll make a
lot to have standards uh not without
being judged right basically
um if you say that you prefer slim women
that go to the gym then women are going
to say you're discriminating against fat
fat man yeah so it's best to stay quiet
to be honest just keep your opinions to
yourself and just do you
oh no that was such a cool answer
I like that that was just like
that was just cool that's me when Kevin
Samuel said that men generally don't
want
baby mamas
and fat chicks
women went crazy
but when women say they don't want short
guys
I'm broke guys everyone's yeah men get
abused
men get abused I feel sorry I feel sorry
for a short mint like if you're under
six foot I feel sorry for you if you're
broke I feel sorry for you I found out a
crazy stat um 80 of women have their
height filter set to what
yeah really yeah eighty percent of women
it's deep like and that's only like on
dating apps and dating apps so a lot of
girls will say my height or taller
because only 15 80 if y'all want a
dating dating app there's an 80 it's
deep though because like as a man like
you can't control how tall you grow do
you know what I mean but like but you
can control how big you are yeah but
then most men won't aesthetically
pleasing women and you can't beat the
evil of course you can you can make
yourself look you can make but if you're
not quote unquote pretty there's
anything yeah
I feel like most girls can't become like
like if you're a five six you can't
really become like an eight exactly but
it but I I do think that no girl is
really going to be below a five if she's
in shape yeah and you can be sure and
have a lot of money and no one will okay
because you know how much harder it is
to make money than to go to the gym and
get in shape no I'm talking about your
your face I'm talking about no but it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter because
like a guy will go for a girl that's got
a dead face here but if her body is
banging she'll bust kiss that's true
she'll first kiss that's true but you're
saying that for a short guy to just get
rich I'm not saying get rich I'm saying
be financially secure do you know how
hard that is just to be stable it is
difficult but it's possible
I'm not saying it's the same I'm never
saying anything is the same I'm saying
it's possible okay the level of the
playing pool is level equal for everyone
an interesting stat if a guy is five
five how much more does he have to make
do you have the same options as a guy
that's it was either five ten or six
foot yeah yeah but why do you need the
same options you don't need enough to be
able to pick you the girl that you want
now okay why do you want to be like okay
like instead of attacking the question
why don't you just give me an answer
what's the question how how much more
does he have to make
options as a guy that's six are you
asking me for a figure guess I don't
have a figure no I'm saying guess I
don't know okay
five to ten thousand more what do you
think
probably like 15 to 20 more than the
general person he has to make 300 000
more have the same options there's a guy
that's six foot can't just say something
what I noticed right is that most women
certainly I'll say I'm a four or five
and everybody's like yeah 32 years
because I'm over average man because I'm
an average woman and that's what I'm
saying and he just makes me feel more
than average and I think I must be about
five five years about five six he's at a
nine to five job for God knows however
long and I'm gonna add more more
property than him but he's got more cash
than me
that's okay you guys are saying that
yeah
this impossible it's like they want a
man that's got this they man a man
that's got that and then when they don't
and then they look back like my man I
don't fit anybody he was always handsome
in my eyes but everybody thought that
they can they can do better
but he's like one of those slow Growers
he was always there he always had
potential and even when I earned more
than him he still gives me money
my money doesn't come into it
differences back then average like
average women would date average guys
well now they don't like women only
swipe right on dating apps five percent
of the time so essentially a hundred
percent of women are fighting over five
percent of men on dating apps it's the
number one way people meet today a lot
of people say it's not real but it's the
number one way people are meeting and
the data is indicating we're sharing
these guys and 80 of 80 of women put
their height filter is six foot or more
um 80 of women or no 100 of women wait
eighty percent of women
women rate 80 percent of men is
unattractive that's what it is so it's
like women average women don't want
average men but you know what's
interesting 80 of women will rate
men to what is it oh sorry women rate 80
of Madison of men as unattractive but
those women that are doing that have
other people's hair on their head they
have makeup or they have makeup on their
face they have fake nails they have fake
eyelashes fake lips fake lips and I've
always said attacks the whole thing and
that said if you were to literally like
Kevin Kevin Kevin strip yourself back
take all the hair off your head that's
not yours take your makeup off have a
shower come out the shower let me see
exactly what you look like right let me
see exactly what you look like when you
go to bed because what it is is that a
lot of modern women think that they are
eights nines and tens and they're really
fives bro you see they're like fives and
a half it's like you've got a lot of
average average women they want access
to the one percent of men you know what
I mean and that's because of obviously
enhancements filters Etc and then you
got hella Sims just gassing you up so
you've got loads of people just feeding
into this like false sense of like
entitlement that you don't have really
because when it comes down to it the one
percent that you're going for they're
never going to take you seriously and
that comes down to the communication as
well because this is always that bad but
communication like the way in which I've
seen some women communicate with men
right that you're on the same level
don't I don't communicate with that man
like you're above the level you're above
his level do you know what I mean it's
like you're communicating with that man
in a certain way because you've got
other people's hair on your head and
you've got your makeup on and you've got
your lashes on and you've got your nails
on but you wouldn't communicate with
that guy the same way if you just
stepped out of the shower with nothing
like that on and a lot of times like
women won't trust a man's judgment
unless he makes over a certain amount of
money and because a lot of times I ask
the question like would you quit your
job if your man told you to and like how
much money would he have to make for him
to do that and most of the time it's
like top five top ten percent of income
but like
it submission is trusting a man's
judgment but average men can't get to
mission anymore
because women are fighting over five
percent of the dating Market ten percent
that's why women say men are trash toxic
acts like if you have an ex that cheated
he was probably top 20 of men most men
don't get sex like that hey as always
when you got like really bang bang
average guys that will come out and
they'll say yeah like I've never cheated
I've never stepped out I've never done
this but like you don't have the option
to
so like it's different when you've got
like the one percent of guys with all
the options in the world there's more
credit to those guys for actually
staying faithful because it's a lot more
difficult than the guy that you've had
that's like
it's like it's a way that men can offer
long-term term security to women as
they'll like say I'm not like these guys
those guys are bad and so it's like a
mating strategy sorry go ahead yeah no I
was saying I just think when it comes to
the cheating thing I I just think men
are built differently to women no matter
how we try to go around it how I might
feel when I see somebody that I think is
attractive I wouldn't go and do it
because
I'm a woman and I'm not made in that way
men can are stimulated in a different
way and they go for what they want so I
thought the cheating thing is very
what's my saying men will have sex with
a whole animal she it is honestly not
the worst thing I can average in a
relationship especially when you learn
to be secure especially when you
understand the real concept of and I
don't like people throwing this whole
loyalty love exclusive you can a man can
be loyal to you in terms of showing up
for you and you need him to in terms of
being committed so you can also do that
and still cheat like it doesn't it's
like I think
there's a lot of insecurity and
possessiveness that I think you were
speaking about earlier that is rooted to
some of these relationships that makes
women want to hold on to this this is
mine and it's like he can be there for
you and give you everything that you
wanted make your list create your menu
that man can give you everything on that
menu and still cheat it does not take
away from who you are like it just yeah
Andrew Tate said it was very interesting
Angie Tate said women don't understand
what loyalty is because they think that
a man being loyal to them is never
cheating right but a man he uses a
scenario of someone who likes apples if
a man always eats apples doesn't mean
he's low to Apples the man that's loyal
to Apples eats apples all the time and
then eats her strawberry but always
comes back to Apples he eats a banana
but always comes back to Apples and that
is what loyalty is loyalty means if if
there's no if there's no alternative I
have no choice but to be loyal to you
and loyalty to a man the way men see it
is like but I'm always coming back to
you that means I'm I don't care about
these other it's just something that was
kind of throwaway
but if I'm always coming back to you
that's what loyalty is I have a question
um for you Sarah actually both both of
you too
um when do you think a man becomes
disloyal
so if he if so if he okay if he he's
sleeping with other girls that doesn't
automatically mean he's disloyal is he
disloyal if like because don't you think
guys on some level ever developed
feelings for the side chick I've heard
stories where like side chicks get
written into the wills that like stuff
like that yeah yeah yeah so so when does
it become disloyal when he like you said
like when he takes his finances and his
time
and gives it to somebody else he's
disloyal so if he has like if I write my
if I had like a mistress okay right and
I'm married and I've got and I write her
into my will that's disloyed is it
disloyalty if he has a whole side chick
in what sense what do you mean okay so
yeah no I think that is this low because
he's given her time and energy that he
could be given to his wife
um a man that's a man that has I don't
know a couple of one-night stands with I
don't know some random chick and comes
back to his wife as a man I don't think
that's but he's just lowering his energy
to someone else yeah but it's like it's
throwaway a man will have sex with a
hole in the world
if a guy has a side chick where it's
just like easier to use her right I'm
just curious when that's like variety as
well so but if he has like a side chick
that it's just like easier to go to her
because sex is hard for men to get and
if he has one you might want to retain
it if he's looking to cheat right and I
just wonder like when is exactly the
line like does he have feelings me
personally I've never had it me
personally I've never had a side chance
that's just me personally I've never had
it I know someone that has I know
somebody hasn't and I know that them
having that side chick took so much time
and effort and also resources out of
them and I was like bro I ain't got time
for that unless unless I would say that
man was disloyed of course but unless
that woman is part of the
conglomerate okay right I've always said
if you want two women they need to know
about each other or streaming they need
to know about each other and they need
to know that this is what what it is but
if you're running around on the side and
it's like you're taking all and you have
to hide and you have to put your phone
down and all this kind of stuff and the
woman can't know
that's not a whole nother relationship
bro like it's just disloyalty now see I
think um there's levels to it in it so
like
if like guys can just trip and fall into
[ __ ] it happens by accident
you can work past that I feel like but
then obviously when you're actually
having a whole nother relationship on
the side that's mad because who's got
time for that and then that is
essentially and like you're doing what
the woman like what you would class is
the woman is being like like this law
because you're investing time anymore
yeah and when does it become a
relationship like how often does he have
to see her for it to become a
relationship if you're banging the same
life it's more than once then it's like
if so if he hooked up with her twice in
a year that's probably not disloyalty so
it's it's right so it has to be a level
of how often it's this law but I'd say
once you get into the realm of like
you're texting every day you're hiding
messages you're deleting stuff yeah when
you start being sneaky yeah then yeah
because you're constantly lying to your
partner at that point like
I don't know whether it's just me but I
know of older West Indian couples where
happily married man
happily married woman on the outside the
wife knows about her they know about
each other and they want class as
disloyal but that's why nobody but she's
part of the conglomerate
she's part of the arrangement you've got
the house children and she's part of the
Arena I remember going out somewhere and
every time I went out I always saw this
older woman don't look at me and I
remember saying to him something about
your wife no something about your
husband that's not my husband and I
thought but I've seen you use it all
together and she was so adamant and
angry that I called
her his wife but I'd seen you together
for like 10 years yeah and then when I
said to someone who is she like you know
I used to work with a guy I thought that
was his wife I used to work with him and
I thought who's that woman that goes no
no that's it's not his wife and then we
went to an official function and then
you say as well then I saw the wife and
the wife just like sort of rolls out on
the official function she's got the big
house you know the kids of raised she's
there with the grandchildren their
husband has got two keys for two houses
one to his home and the women they don't
argue they don't see each other because
she's smart she's partly around it's not
seen as this lion
those women have escaped The Matrix
they're getting they're getting the the
full benefit of the man in his whole
prison the thing is it's not mine
because she's got the kids she's got the
pension she's got a house and she hasn't
got that everything everything you
wanted you're getting and once you've
started to detach from this idea of
owning people it's not that deep if you
understand that it's not a worse thing
that can happen at your mind speaking
somebody else who's attracted to someone
that you're so secure in what you like
it don't mean nothing and more time
another thing that I've also realized
with this whole cheating thing women
aren't busy enough you've got too much
time on your hands to be coming to do
digging up like if you had your own [ __ ]
you would not even be concerning
yourself what you're quote unquote
management because you're getting taken
care of that's what another thing I
wanted to point out but yeah um I have a
side trick I've told Auntie this before
I have a side chick story
um I know someone that was like very
Catholic so she was like the most the
most one of the most Catholic people
I've ever met like she she believes in
hell she believes in heaven like she
went to church I read it like that sort
of thing she was married to someone
um for I don't know 50 years total but
about like 20 30 years in the the her
husband had an affair with someone at
work
and he actually left the family to go to
the side chick he left his family and
she prayed to God for a solution she
said God like she she didn't believe in
divorce so she's like please bring him
back together she believed that like
salvation for her husband like wouldn't
be offered if he really left and he
really committed adultery and didn't
come back so she prayed to God for a
solution the side chick died
[Laughter]
and they stayed married for 50 years
and everything I remember my late
Godfather and he was like he was one of
the best golfer ever used to sit there
and chat he was happily married he had
his children from his wife
and when he died and she found his will
he had a whole other family out there
and he had she didn't know about she
didn't lose any money she didn't lose
any house had properties in Barbados
that had properties here
but he had this whole other family that
and they had a house and he had children
and the wife was really upset and I
thought but you only found out when he
died you know it didn't bother you it
didn't take away she didn't notice or
anything like that and he
and he
everybody was happy when he'd everybody
was like well taken care of when he died
his other family and my aunt and he was
a fantastic man but I don't know how he
kept it secret because he had a whole
other family going on and nobody knew
about it and he just went to work it was
always a hard worker so over time I
think that's where the overtime went the
overtime none of the women suffered
nobody suffered none the family suffer
Diva question about like they got the
money from his male and female different
ways of men and women communicating
um what I've kind of seen in this new
generation of women right is women feel
that they can communicate
with men like men and when I say that I
mean this like the confrontation that
I've seen some women
um act with men can be very masculine
I've seen women be like
poke men in their heads boss up on
they're looking at me like you know that
acts like men with men because men I've
always said like men communicate in a
certain way right
if myself and Mr beard gang over here
right if I was to square up to them it
would be a situation doesn't matter I'm
not saying who's gonna win who's going
to lose it it's going to be a situation
because I know as a man I've got a tread
carefully with other men and I've
noticed that when it comes to
communication with men women of this
generation modern women think that they
can communicate with men like men that
they can I've seen women boss up in
men's faces like push man and all this
kind of stuff and I'm like
do you understand that kind of do you
understand what that means no I hear you
I want to speak because I've had an
experience
um of acting as such a man I had to
check myself as a result of seeing
myself and when I speak about my
experience the only thing that I was
able to make sense of is the fact that I
come from a similar environment that has
conditioned me to quote unquote Express
relative masculine energy and
expressions and I had to see it in
myself to realize that you're not acting
like a lady but at the same time I come
from a single parent home I'm from
quote-unquote South London I used to
fight a lot when I was younger I used to
be really into sports so in my younger
years for the most I used to be a tomboy
like when I my mum it was just my mum me
and my sisters so when someone comes to
the door I used to be able to go to the
door something's broken in the house I
so I didn't even realize I was being
conditioned and adopting some of these
masculine traits so when I am when I
used to find myself in quote-unquote
confrontation arguments I didn't realize
that I was rather than famine and
squaring up but it took me a while to
really do you ever get punched in the
face by me I did actually did you yeah
it did it stop here
how is your face not like he had to slap
do you not punch Oh no I got punched
about it wasn't me it wasn't I'm just
thinking if a dude hit you full force it
was your face it wasn't full force the
personal question wasn't yeah yeah
um yeah um and that was my only ever
experience in doing that but I just I I
even though I do feel like I was
antagonized and the person played a part
in it I do see how I facilitated that
when I checked myself where did I come
from why did you act like that you can
communicate in all manner that can you
know get better results and I understand
that that's not effective when you're
actually trying to get results with men
I thought where did that come from and I
realized you know where it came from how
I got brought up I used to pretty much
act like a boy so they should speak like
a boy it's like a self-dundance girl but
it's taking me a while past 25 to
realize that you know what you actually
just because you of where you come from
doesn't mean you can't be feminine and
use your femininity to get results when
it comes to interactive women so well
well done for doing the work on yourself
do you
um because
I've seen um
you see with that type of woman that
type of communication where where women
think that they're men I've said I've
been out like on a night out right and
I've seen women
who feel this who feel aggrieved about a
way a man neither spoke to her or
treated her a certain way and she's been
up in a man's Facebook but she's been
with her boyfriend that's the worst
right that's the worst time Lord have
mercy one of my things is
because women are women they don't
understand what danger is right you
don't know and women understand danger
when it comes to other men like sexual
danger grape and sexual assault and that
kinds of stuff those kind of stuff but
when it comes to like physical violent
danger I feel like women don't
understand what it is and it's like I've
seen on a couple of occasions a woman
with a boyfriend and she's another man
has been with like five dudes and she's
been napping and I've been like you are
about to let your boyfriend die today
your boyfriend's gonna get effed up
today because you don't understand that
if you don't learn to shut the f up
right your boyfriend's gonna have to
jump in and defend you right and he's
gonna get jumped by about like five
dudes my mom would say you're on your
own mate
there's no way my man gonna jump in to
save me if I start some rubbish like
that women like that yeah
that's what men need to do men need to
wise up to women when they're doing that
rubbish if us every woman pokes you just
let's walk around either
I would say slap her down but there's
the cameras around myself and
men they they just need to wise up if I
get my if I went out there with my man
and I started an argument he was saying
like is that what your brain told you to
say okay
even if I raise my voice you know
something yeah it's like um um check
yourself I'm like do you know what's
funny because you stop me there check
yourself my cell phone powered on it I'm
just gonna say an anecdote little story
anecdotal Story Time myself empowered
dinner podcast with a certain woman and
um let's just say this woman did not
like me very much on the podcast right
we had issues and
what I what what happened was is that I
think she didn't mind you at the podcast
I think it was the edits that came it
was edit yeah so once the edits came out
and the clips came out she didn't like
me like she went on some this guy's this
and he's I don't like Sarah and blah
blah blah and um I saw her again like a
couple months later and I was just like
listen yo no beef here like no but cool
she's like I don't like you and like a
couple of days later like in my inbox on
like Instagram her boyfriend had come in
my inbox I don't like the way you spoke
to my girl
and I was like you know what whatever
she told you she's put a battery in your
back bro and I'm not saying that I'm a
gangster or anything like that but women
like that will literally send their man
out into the field to go and defend
their honor right yeah defend my honor
and then when the guy gets Eva into
trouble with the police or effed up
she's nowhere to be seen when the
bullets start flying women not know what
to be seen women will gas a guy up like
to go and get effed up and there'll be
nowhere to be seen afterwards men needs
to get wise that it needs to get wise
Bros composure it's so easy to put a man
in this place without having to get
yourself out of it why would you want to
be putting them out
oh gosh
this place do you know what men have
been doing when they come up to me now
on the streets some of them they don't
seem to like me very much from this
podcast so they gentleman handle me grab
me a bit too tough on the shoulder slap
my shoulders a bit too hard and I'm like
listen this guy's about to really piss
me off but it's okay and I tell him
every single time with my composure
don't forget that I'm still a woman who
are you to be manhandling me like that
please take your hands off me easy you
don't need to get angry he feels stupid
and he leaves you alone that's all you
need so I think that sometimes like
girls
take a deep breath and hit the nail on
the head with what you say composure
just Twisted that was your best point
this is that whole situation right he
was talking about the women going out
there and making their mango out and she
just twists
in a woman we weren't talking about a
man touching a woman no I'm just saying
shut their mouth don't have composure to
be more feminine
and to maybe learn to think before you
speak hey because you think
that it's always us looking for trouble
looking for trouble for me all the time
because you don't go looking for trouble
no why would a man come and put his hand
on you well ask him because I told him
I'm so don't put your hand on me what's
wrong with you why are you talking to
you who do you think caps more men about
how much they get laid or women about
how much they get approached women about
how much they can approach that's what
every girl says and you know what a guy
said to me he saw me on the tube the
camera don't do your Justice and I was
like well thank you that's a good way to
approach me I believe in equal rights
equal laughs I feel like if you hit
someone you should get hit back say that
not right
isn't it I just feel like if you I
wouldn't hit someone and not expect to
get hit back it couldn't be like oh you
hit me I think the reactive thing is
also especially scoring lots of people
outside when you under the influence and
you've got this extra gassy that you can
do it until you get hit you're like oh
my God I can't believe what I've just
done right I've just said one slap yeah
that's it different I've only got
brothers so I know
it's never my thing to do and I've
watched how my mum behaves or moves of
just how much she doesn't have to do
anything I mean but you people do get
triggered and if they feel like they're
in a situation it's reminding them of
when this person did the same they're
getting everything that that person did
before so yeah being reflective and
realizing what the situation actually is
before reacting I think is important I'm
looking past physicality as well because
obviously men are physically bigger than
us and they might have certain
mannerisms that might make you feel
threatened but it's not intentional that
doesn't mean that you can now try and
use your body to try and intimidate him
backwards
this calm down and think about it calm
down go away and come back and think
about it before you act if more women
will stop take a deep breath think it
through walk away and come back don't do
anything when you're upset don't do
anything when you're emotional don't
even cook because when you cook when
you're emotional the food don't do
nothing what if you're emotional shut
yourself down God you know what say that
sorry love but you know what any time
alone right now because you know what I
mean like it's [ __ ] go away the men
will understand that yeah I'm crazy I
need an hour
I'd say this [ __ ] like if you're an
attractive woman you need to understand
like
you are inherently dangerous to your men
like when you're walking down the street
as a man it's more dangerous walking
down the road with an attractive woman
than it is a gold chains around your
neck like I took my girl to Carnival
like we just thought yeah went to
Westfield we'll go for a walk yeah right
we'll go through we'll go and walk
through Carnival see what it's saying
yeah dangerous situation Carnival bro
dangerous situation you're asking for
trouble dangerous situations
guys that say people are troubling
people's elbows and truck Carnival bro
your elbow is not safe every elbow your
elbow is not safe in carnival and and
for her it was a big eye-opening as well
because she realized that right like
it's actually dangerous me walking down
the road with you so I need to actually
carry myself in a certain type of way
where I'm not going to attract any
attention or danger I mean but a lot of
women don't actually realize this they
don't actually clock how dangerous it is
women are dressed sexy when they go
outside but how sexy are they when
they're at home for their man right and
it's more dangerous to be inside sexier
than your man we need to get more sexy
for the men indoors sweep the laundry
for at home he's like going out of your
menu with your titties out and your ass
out is dangerous because all it all it
takes is one guy to be able to cackle
you or try and grab you and your man's
not looking and then there's a situation
you imagine I've got to defend your
honor that's right a whole issue that
didn't need to happen no but it's just
it's just like just dressing some kind
of class in decorums you know I mean
like you can still be sexy you can still
be sexy but classy six classy at the
same time like you don't need to be
showing all yours
no yeah because I kind of like
sensuality I like being able to be free
I mean not saying that I need to be have
a battery Riders out my tits out all the
time but I want my man or whoever I'm
with to be secure and the fact that not
that you're insecure if I'm getting
um approached but that that's you're
with me you know what Mar of course but
you know what this is but like I don't
want guys to be looking at looking at
your woman like even if you've got
you don't think there's a difference
between like wearing like a super tight
dress and like a flowy one just to be a
little bit more respected when you got
hips and thighs and breasts you can't
always hide it and sometimes I'm I could
be in a if I was wearing a dress that
you're wearing now I'd still probably
have enough I understand that like
different body types but you don't you
have some dresses that are more
conservative and some that are more
revealing and wouldn't it if you're in a
relationship make more sense to where
your more conservative dresses
I want to ask a question about that
because ultimately
doesn't that that you sometimes want to
also see me sexy because I'm not going
to wear the tight dress as women as as
women you have standards yourself like
you know like I can't have my boobs and
my legs out okay you know what I mean so
you've got to think
like you can't if you're going to go out
of your mind for dinner and you've got
your titties out your ass out your legs
out it's just too much a bit of money
yeah
I think sometimes as a woman you can get
to a stage of fashion Evolution where
you can understand subtlety and sexiness
and you can dress grown and elegant but
still have that you know that hint that
makes you feel like yeah I'm that girl
and actually when men see you they rate
you they probably will desire you in
their head but they'll never approach
it's a different type of respect to
cover up a little you're still sure
you've got body but you cover up a
little bit and it's not all about
covering up and how you look it's
how you speak and how you conduct
yourself as well true because you can
look classy and sexy and open your mouth
and sound like a dumb [ __ ]
I agree why is that an indirectly I'm
just saying it out there you know it's
not all about the clothing sometimes
it's about you know you cannot put your
mouth and you think oh I have a question
for the guys okay okay would you pick
you have two girls equal attractiveness
one girl when you go out
dress is like a hoe but she speaks
classy the other girl
dresses modest but every time she opens
her mouth it's trashy that's a good
question that's a very good question
look all looks are the same everything
else
I know I know you'd pick neither but
this is more fun you gotta pick one and
why yeah
listen I don't how often does she have
to open them up
like if she doesn't have to open them up
that often then I might just take the
one that's got no I mean she's trashy
mouth what trash what girl that has a
trashy mouth doesn't open it that you
know yeah but the thing is I don't want
you looking like a hole on the street
all the time okay so you pick that
because because human beings like they
judge people based on visuals before
they even open their mouth you get what
I'm saying so I don't wanna yeah I don't
want to be around a woman who takes her
to a restaurant where she has to keep on
eating so she don't yeah
what you want steak sauce chips there
you go yeah so mashed potatoes go for it
so with one it's like they would know
she's a hoe but the other one you can
maybe hide it if you can you could hide
it yeah exactly if you keep a drinking
and eating okay what about you oh do you
know what like
I'm a big conversationalist so
I don't know what I would do is I'd
choose the restaurant and I'd get there
early pick a table right at the back in
the corner which I mean so that no one
can see and like I'll make her face the
wall
yeah and then we can have a good
conversation the Uber's outside quick
exit and then let's go do you see how
pragmatic man
they have two different solutions for
these problems that's an interesting
that have like have you found as women
like have you found that the men in your
life are literally uh um are more
logical than you and is that is that a
lack of turn on for you or a turn off
turn on
I enjoy the time
no so can we go yeah oh I wanted I said
yeah
I think it teaches me something so wow
like I didn't have to
make everything so big so you can just
sit down and I like the fact that I can
find Solutions and I enjoy being around
masculine energy that teach me how to
just like you know work things out so
yeah that's my answer
um
it's to turn on now but at a point in
time it wasn't because I wasn't
I wasn't ready to hear the logic I
wanted to be babied right
um and obviously that also comes from
like upbringing and like how your
parents treat and deliver you so yeah
okay so yeah but now yeah I've always
been quite lucky in that sense I've
always had like relationships where the
Mao has kind of been like the mountain
and it's just like still and calm and
I've always been quite good at like
reflecting on when like the energy of
motion inside me is well enough as to
like understand that I'm being triggered
by something right and to have that
space held for me without it me being
like it's you me being like I know I'm
in a tears right now can you just like
chill a second and like just hold the
space so yeah I'm quite and yeah it's
definitely attractive when you know that
you're like being held around here
aren't you oh no I said go to Genova oh
yeah I love logic
it's actually it's actually a Pity that
you don't display any but you know you
love you love a logical man yeah I do
it's just easier I just like things that
it's like one plus one equals two that's
it
okay this is she won the mathematician I
am quite the mathematician actually I'll
tell you that
logic works for me yeah he's worn me
down he's turned him into his perfect
woman I've always been logical because I
was a tomboy but
I think according to him
he's making sure I've Got the Right Mix
of femininity and logical and get rid of
the emotional [ __ ]
so if I feel emotional I was just
getting I can't find a Motorway
I'm gonna get rid of that emotion no I
think
no I think after 32 years
otherwise you're gonna are you gonna
converse with I mean I feel like you
have an emotional reaction initially
like especially as someone who's in
literally the most logical like part of
YouTube you know yeah but like you have
an emotional reaction initially but it's
kind of like guys around you can train
you to like look at things a different
way and know when you read like when you
have that like gut reaction to like wait
wait or you know um like for for example
um like the two-day thing I think that's
been really helpful in my life or even
when I'm in a heated debate like my mom
would always tell me like the person
that gets emotional first they lose so
stay stay very calm and don't don't
raise your voice like just stay stay
cool as a cute it is stuff like that
where like they kind of train you a
little bit but they're not I think women
try to trigger an emotional many women
try to trigger an emotional reaction out
of a man and you know what I really like
the fact that WhatsApp you can delete
the messages from everyone
you know that only works when they
haven't read it right so you need to be
quick
don't leave it like because once they
see it
okay
I do it and yeah you're right you know
because
it doesn't go Blue it doesn't always
have to go Blue you have to go through
to see if he's seen it yeah exactly and
then I delete it and that's why he
laughs at me he's like you really feel I
was going to read that crap yeah he's
read it but the thing is it's like I'm
not texting angry again yeah that angry
text is like funny those angry texts are
trying to draw men into your
to women's like and I realized that
that's why I have to stop myself you
know what's crazy you realize you don't
want a solution because that's kind of
one thing my dad whenever I get really
frustrated about something most of the
time with my dad it's actually about
like work stuff but he he's like why are
you getting mad like what's the solution
like you can't get mad at the problem
like you have to think about the
solution so like if you're thinking like
he does that that and that you do blah
blah blah like you're not you're not
telling him what the solution is and
it's really hard because you're just
like bad but I for me that's always
helped me just be like very solution
minded and men are always going to look
for a solution that's why when women
come home from work and be like oh my
God this happened at work and so and so
did this and and man will sit there
listen like
[Music]
does at any point men enjoy the slight
like emotional or sensitivity that women
come with I think I think men enjoy
being able
to be the solution for their woman okay
I think Mama finds it funny yeah like I
think I think it's quite enjoyable
There She Goes Again and he's like yeah
she's all and sometimes it's not me
because there's some weird women out
there that keep away from my man but
there's some weird women out there that
will send texts you know who you are but
you're following me I don't care whether
you follow me you're not my friend so
don't be subscribing to me because
you'll meet you up no that's cooking my
mental of rice anyway so remember to see
all this kind of stuff right and they
will look at it and they were thinking
like yeah right that's funny because
that's emotional so look at you like
they showed me he shows me the Sexes
look yeah look at that
she dances of that yeah and
that's funny because we
because one of emotional something to
try and draw the men in because they
want a reaction especially if they think
that men's logic there's something to
say is being hot-headed so they're like
I'm gonna push this button then maybe he
would do this and you'll find that
they'll send one text it don't work they
send another text yeah yeah then it's in
a voice voice note and it don't work
then they want to call you if he doesn't
answer the phone don't call back he'll
call you no don't work and then you'll
find that the women exhausted themselves
and the man's just sitting there like
what's your name
Comedian says that he's learned in the
way in which women argue and he said if
if if if you beat a woman biologic in an
argument what she's doing he said that
she's concocting right this Hail Mary
argument to just throw at you just to
get you to like react
so you can just call her a [ __ ] elephant
and then once you do that like once you
call her that or you do that thing she's
like she's one oh my God
and then it's like you've lost because
now you've like you've you've bought
into her you can't you can't fight in
the same battle yeah you can't fight
because you will lose every time
into it too it makes us more emotional
than if like I feel like we kind of
almost mirror the guys a little bit or
if the guy's really calm it kind of
forces you to stay a little bit calmer
yeah yeah I prefer that yeah me too you
can't remember otherwise you can go
crazy and I'll be real
I've dated women and I feel like I
learned a lot about myself when there's
a certain routine and I know that that
message is coming and you're going to
send that message again then you're
going to disappear for an hour and let
nothing happen it's really not cool it's
not cool and it made me look at myself
in a way like why did I ever do that
because I know I'm reading the message
that I'm not even replying to it maybe
this is the cure
dating did dating women make you
appreciate man yeah well yeah but well
when I went to Africa it did yeah
[Music]
absolutely rooting for them because I
feel like it's different and I was
dating women for a long like four or
five oh my gosh don't worry for a while
yeah and then I went to Ghana and I was
like oh
you're so strong the men are men you
want to hold my bag yeah oh I like this
you know what I mean so yeah but yeah
it's so funny on a different note I find
that mentality amazing that you could
switch
men if a man has I'm gonna I dated a guy
for four years
but now now I'm not two women I'm cool I
have a question did you did you start
dating women after like a toxic
relationship with a guy
oh never really thought about it and how
old were you when you started and
stopped dating women
oh stop oh gosh we haven't stopped we
didn't stop we're just just okay well
when you you took a step
um but yeah um
age twin about 20 it's not about 24.
okay and yeah until 29 was when you
finished yeah okay can I ask a question
and was it after no she don't like
relationships
oh sorry I was about yeah 16 when I went
into my first relationship and it lasted
a very long period of time I was
intermitting me and the guy were in
church together and I kind of felt like
I had to be in that room
[Laughter]
um
is it otherwise you know I'm gonna go to
hell well which is not really not a good
way to think about it but no honestly
that that's what it was I found that
like when girls start dating girls it's
usually after a toxic relationship and
they either start or stop around 28 to
like
31.50 yeah
so stop because like typically a lot of
times they may want like the family unit
and so then they'll go back or they kind
of age out of the this is just
observations in my opinion
um they age out of the dating Market
with like men and so then they start to
date women because they can't get the
men they want anymore interesting
um I always thought their boy ran I
always thought to myself that women
sometimes they're in toxic relationships
or they have been and they just need
time out of a woman
just to feel like a woman again
never took after a toxic relationship
they like don't even want to be the man
yeah like go to a woman and the second
is like I feel like it's usually they
can't get the like compete for the men
they want anymore yeah and like they
always say like girls would rather be
with a woman than settle for a beta and
so sometimes the women are more pushed
too I could be as I can men can be sick
of women they could be like oh my God
I'm never gonna go and get a man are you
crazy
it's different it's all about
penetration that's why it's different
well I think I think there's like a I
forget
the penetration women
um they did a study where women like to
see when what women were aroused by and
they found that like women cap a lot
about what they're aroused by like they
would say where you aroused by this
image that image that image and they
would say no no no and I don't remember
and like then they would see I don't
know maybe I don't know how they
measured it but there's some way you can
like tell right and like a lie detector
type thing no it wasn't a lie detector
like I think when you're aroused like
your heart rate go
something I don't know what medically it
was I just know they measured or like
something in your brain lights up or
something and I remember like women
capped a lot about not be like about
being attracted to other women or like
the majority of women actually were
attracted to other women oh yeah that's
yeah that's very attractive but
sometimes
the way you've grown up but also I also
remember women find 80 of men
unattractive so like women again I think
like if women can't get a certain
percentage of men like this okay they'd
rather date a woman I think women are
more comfortable to practice intimacy
within the agenda but I wanted to ask
guys right a woman yeah that decided to
go and be with other women it's been
with like 50 women the Asia 304 for
example 100 yeah so women counts as body
the same way oh 100 okay so if she was
with 10 men and 10 women
I want to do it would you rather okay
would you rather date a girl she's I've
already been there she's got she's got
10 bodies from guys five from girls or
would you rather have vice versa no sun
bodies from girls five from guys because
of my past experience I'd prefer her to
have bodies from guys
what can you say what went wrong because
of my past experience like I was like
when I was young like I was in my 20s my
second like major relationship
I was in a relationship with a woman who
was bisexual right and at that age I was
like 20 that was early twenty oh but I
said that's great yeah great no well
exactly for you yeah threesome wow they
just because it's like if you fall in
love with somebody who's a who's a
bisexual
and they come to you one day and say ah
women you're like uh I can't compete
with that as a man because men as in the
competition because as a man I'm I'm
competitive by Nature because I want to
be able to quote unquote please my woman
and I'm like hang on so what I'm doing
is not pleasing you could say nobody
knows a woman like a woman like I was
like oh snap like yeah I'm not enough
you need to leave then like my thing was
that okay you need to go because if I'm
not enough for you clearly then you just
not where you need to be so as a man
who's experienced it I was like nah I'm
not down for that women that like
women's stuff that's just me too much
you pick it'd be too much headache
because I wouldn't know who I'm
competing with so yeah she could be like
Oh I'm going on a girl's night
[Applause]
it's a slippery slope it is a really
slippery slope when I get her romance
perspective why they'd be like because
people that aren't like a bit naive to
it and just think oh it's just silly
there's a there's a lot of things that
can happen between two women and yeah so
it is a lot to do like if you're going
out of your girls and then you don't
come back and like if my girl I know
she's 100 straight like then I know for
a fact that she's just gone back to her
friend's house right they've they're
gonna have something I'm going to sleep
you know what I mean but like if I know
that you like women as well then like
you could be getting freaky with your
friend that's it bro and the thing is
you can't compete with that you can't
it's like when like you just don't know
there's a I think there's a um there's a
there's an ego in men also you know what
I mean like if if if you're as a man you
understand you're you're competing with
other men for a woman you understand
that
and that's your competition
when you are out of the league
and and if you know that you can't
compete you just have to throw your
hands up I'd say the only way that could
be like like the only way it could work
yeah is if it's a case where if you're
playing away too then I'm involved
I have a question for the guys too I
just thought of this a little off topic
but would you rather have a girl that
has a string of x's that are better than
you or significantly worse than you
and like guys judge a Girl by her axes
and the quality a guy she in keep rights
that's on one hand but on the other hand
if it's too high of a quality you can't
compete so like and and please don't
give me the answer guys there's no guy
that can't can't compete with like okay
it's it's Leonardo DiCaprio it's some
whoever your guy hero is it's him
I I would I would prefer a woman who
it's either him or like like Pookie and
like yeah just give me the Countess give
me the girl just have to Pookie and ray
rays over over the X's that we're taking
oh yeah because now because if I show
you this level you're like she's gonna
be like oh my god I've never experienced
this before wow you're like he bought my
meal oh my gosh my hero yeah exactly
except the guy was like what I was on a
yacht like last year
okay what about you ah yeah
um
I'd have to say a draw of my girl had
guys that were of high value because I
rate myself as that so
so you drive with your girl your your
girl's ex was Michael B Jordan oh my God
calm yeah because because you know what
the way I see it I say I think that and
he showed her whole life for two years
but then I got one up on him which is
good because I've got her do you know
something I'm with him no I hear that no
no I'm with him because
okay okay like I said my man is average
and I've been out with CEOs and every
everyone before
and
let me let me add some more of Amanda
because even though the money you know
why because that's the man that I know
but let me let me add one thing keep it
heat let me add one thing he died he
they had to have dumped her
it wasn't her choice
the whole point is like that was the ACT
she couldn't keep
so Michael B Jordan showed her the
millionaire lifestyle
bought her at 10 000 roses on balance
and then he's like yeah see you later
love and then you're dealing with that
and she's thinking about my [ __ ] off
all right I said that's too much to
compete with it's a curveball but at the
same time like [ __ ] happens in
relationships man like I could have
ended for any reason
how do you feel knowing that yoga would
have been dumped by a waste man
I I don't mind a woman that hasn't
experienced a certain type of lifestyle
and then I introduce her to a lifestyle
I I reckon if I think you'll probably
got a good point still because if if she
was done by the waist man now you come
not only are you the hero yeah you also
can understand that maybe like yeah he
moved them to be just missed out on
somebody
and she and she feels like oh my god
what have I done to deserve this man
because all of my life I've had men that
wouldn't even buy me a KFC meal do you
realize that Davina just says something
logical Davina you know I'm sorry that's
okay
Queen is fine Empress I think at this
point Auntie you're doing it purposely
you know what I'm saying
um I was just saying yeah I think that
if obviously giving my opinion I
probably would have said that the best
girl would have been the one that was
done by the waste man because she will
your the standards that you're bringing
are probably going to be appreciated a
lot more because at the end of the day
people tend to compare what was I then
or am I now you know so you want to
progress not necessarily digress but
then it obviously depends on the details
of the conversation and how why did they
dump what happened less than your
business already and you're gonna ask
that oh is that no no no well I don't
know and the thing is like that the
things you're talking about may not even
make any difference like a guy can fly
go out here fly a dare put her on a boat
but in reality if you're the one that's
actually given her like real time and
value then that might mean more so
imagine a high value guide that treats
it nicely and then dumps her because
actually it's not working out and then
she comes going to be living in regret
because yeah because she's going to be
like you know last year I was in
Mauritius right and he was nice
stay married past like 45 because you
know Tom Brady just fell with Giselle
with Giselle I wanna see can a woman
come back from Leonardo Dicaprio and
stay married it's crazy because we'll
find out I I think I think we talk about
the alpha Widow right like women get
Alpha Widow yeah like when you're
widowed by an alpha
yeah it sounds really weird I actually
hate the word Alpha but I'm so used to
using it okay it's basically like okay
do you do you know a girl that has that
X she always runs back to and can't get
over yeah okay basically that girl sees
that guy as the best she could have done
and some people argue that that's
usually the best sex she's ever had so
like sometimes we'll be like why him but
like that's why and it doesn't matter
who comes next she's always gonna go
back to him and the thing is there's
like accounts of women that are in
nursing homes that still think about a
guy from like their teens in their 20s
that's how powerful that's how powerful
it is and and like basically
historically typically
if us all were in like a tribe right and
our guy got killed they would get rid of
the women or take the women and get rid
of the children so we they think that
women had to historically like Get over
one guy to get to the other and they
would always be with the like strongest
most Alpha guy and like historically we
wouldn't be with someone that's like
weaker and like women can't handle that
is what they what they think it is it's
true so that's what I'm saying so you
see me though I don't want to be like if
a woman's Alpha Widow did you see me I
prefer to be the alpha Widow you see me
I like Alpha widows women I like to play
Life on hard mode so if I if I know if I
know a personal footballer then she's
used to a certain type of Lifestyle so I
know that I need to level up whatever
I'm gonna work to try and ain't gonna
work
because I was out for we done that's the
man I'm with now
and everyone I've been with knows his
name and we discussed it the other day
and I said isn't that a bit weird you
went back to All My Exes
yeah that was the best doctor that's the
best for me 32 years I'm counting yeah
but before that everybody knows his name
was that because of the sex though no
because it's amazing he's the man from
which your men should be made
that's good look at that look at the
smile that's on Auntie's face
I wish my woman would be like that 32
years after I met her
because this came up before in
conversation I was talking about Alpha
video and I thought about it and I
thought if I could if I found my except
and say guess what man that I ended up
with they know his name that's pretty
bad they know his name because I never
hit it and I never had it I was I always
I always said if I said oh you're
another message that was stupid you're
not someone's I can't be enough with you
look at you and looking but I was quite
honest and open about it because I
couldn't know better he was the best
ever a lot of guys find out that like
and this is just like talking to guys
about their observations of women that
the toxic acts that the women can't like
stop talking about that's the one who
they actually loved because think about
it if you really didn't like a guy
you're not really going to talk about
him you don't even care after you guys
break up but when you're really into a
guy he really broke your heart that's
the one you complain about that's right
and so like I hate him that's just
another way I loved him he did break my
heart though we just had it's just
something came up and we separated but
yeah you got him now Auntie yeah I don't
think you separate from it
um about four or five years because I I
found out I got my condition at a name
it was um
oh gosh I saw it on TV yesterday not
insomnia
sex Omnia that's right
that's what I had and what happens
insomnia when you suffer from insomnia
and you have sex but the person that
you're with thinks you're awake because
your eyes are open you're going for the
motions and that's why we split because
I thought you had sex with me while I
was sleeping but I got diagna diagnosed
while we split up that I was actually
sleepwalking but I used to drive in a
pair in clubs and that and I was
actually having sex with him but he
thought I was awake and unusual you were
asleep
we've been writing for like over two
hours now folks um Pearl if you do the
super chess and then we can like do that
yeah yeah okay guys um make sure you
like the video subscribe to the channel
ring that notification Bell a like is
the most important metric that YouTube
uses and there's over 2 000 of you in
here so we should have two thousand
likes so like 3 000 I think is 93 000 oh
sure yeah there's three thousand you're
right you're right you're right
um so let me Let me refresh this really
quick also guys um we have go subscribe
to Pearl behind the scenes I want to get
monetized on there I'm gonna be doing
live streams with a show guests so we'll
come to my my room and we hang out and
we like react to videos freestyle like
that sort of thing it's a lot of fun
okay
just Mouse she's coming to you because
the Michael B Jordan's have ran through
her and she's now with you the
relationship won't last she'll cheat
megan51 the first impression is a
lasting one um Nicholas denalva needs to
stay away from kids don't ruin a kid's
life I didn't do it the more I hear you
talk and speak truth and see your
perfectly healthy gums um the more I'm
surprised you're not wiped up yet also
Pearl would you date a man who makes 50k
50k a year uh Tracy Robinson um I think
Sarah is correct the disloyalty comes
from a man investing more of his money
energy and attention and time to a woman
who's not his wife nor a part of his
family great show as always sibo and see
you um so how does denalva's family
situation work when the baby's dad's got
to move is she okay with potentially
losing custody to that guy this whole
scenario only works in a world where
nothing ever changes top bras 88 a man's
broken a man's broken loyalty happens
when he comes home and he is not
tolerated and not appreciated
Augustus on Goldstein guys guys got to
have standards and communicate them for
anything serious gotta have boundaries
too and be prepared to walk away if
they're disrespected Al don't feel sorry
for me brother I'm five six and my
number is at least a hundred Brooklyn
New York stand up okay danella you are
cherry picking the best case scenario of
a single mother household versus the
worst case scenario of a two-parent
household also that sense of possession
couples have is the is the same a parent
has for their kids Johnny Styles that's
why I lie in dating apps and say I'm and
say I'm six feet tall stay toxic Kings
so Danelle the stock has dropped below
zero and her friend zone will be empty
tomorrow
um Gustavus gold sign for Janelle but
kids don't ask to be here you bear that
responsibility
um Kirby I love Auntie jamming over
there so based uh Gary this this is the
Witchcraft of modern day women save them
Auntie Al Denali as every man's dream
side chick she belongs to the streets
cray um danelva is always capping she is
thinking of the peers not the kids also
and ain't this ain't the Nova show [ __ ]
the batowski sickness Mr missing it's a
sickness it is deviant and we don't want
it MVP janelba that's a Super Friends
with Benefits men don't want that
um yeah sorry
uh let me just see if there's any that's
it okay right
um okay we're gonna wrap up um before we
wrap up we're gonna get final thoughts
from everybody so we'll start over here
when it comes to the um the topic
whether it's Silent Communication
between men and women what's your final
thoughts final thoughts um I think we
just
know and understand that sometimes you
are functioning from a place of emotion
and think about the outcome that you're
trying to achieve each I know right or
someone trying to get a reaction or
you're trying to actually get a solution
like what's the outcome those are my
final thoughts I think okay yeah yeah
take a deep breath take a couple days
honestly I think it's important to be
reflective and evolve as a person
because a lot of things that might have
worked for you and you were growing up
and don't work in adult life and if you
actually want to be with somebody you
need to work on that otherwise it's just
not gonna work and Choose Wisely set
yourself up for the right mate
yeah I think I think it's good to be
able to express your emotions energy
emotion but be aware that it is energy
emotion and always like have a little
moment to actually think about whether
I feel like I'm just kind of echoing
what you guys said but yeah actually if
there is actually going to be an outcome
or a solution or if it's just you
blowing up and not really understanding
what's going on internally use your
emotions as like signposts okay rather
than
and I would say be logically honest
that's it
[Laughter]
Mr beard gang uh advice for demanding if
you're arguing with your girl State your
point walk away let it marinate wait two
days then come back
[Laughter]
question for you yeah go ahead they want
to know if you ever apologize to your
exes Oliver
I went around one by one because I I
made the men's suffer when I was going
through trauma so it was only fair that
I apologized hmm yeah so I did
personally hunt them down
if it was weird but I did because it
made me free
so yeah I did because I was a [ __ ]
good women are hard to find in these
days I think that my closing for is I
think everybody should buy a copy of Men
Are from Mars women are from Vegas by
that gray guy and if you've had it read
it again and again
and again and highlight it and again
especially the women because then you
won't talk so much crap and understand
where men are coming from
can I say one last thing
another last thing it's my birthday
[Applause]
don't go too deep no why don't you tell
them about the cash app
oh yeah uh okay so for my birthday I
said I don't want to get gifts all the
time because why are you gonna spend
five pounds on a box of chocolates when
you can give that to me so we can put it
towards a nice event together we
celebrate together so I started to go
for me I said if everybody gives me five
pounds I only need 100 people to give me
500 I've raised 725 pounds so far so
thank you guys thank you cutting up on
Saturday tell them tell them the
GoFundMe link right you'll find the
GoFundMe link on my bio it's uh my
Instagram is denalva.ao for those of you
who get my name wrong it's Delta India
November Alpha Lima Victor Alpha dot
Alpha era Oscar there you go the novel
dot AO or you can go to my Instagram and
just look in my following or di it'll
come out
foreign
I've kept the location cryptic because
you'll get to know if you put your name
on the guest list or the GoFundMe but
now that it's my birthday I'll open it
up a little bit more so do people have
to pay to go or well you don't have to I
just to be honest if you're my close
people you don't have to but I do put
the go for me there so you can do a
donation because it's gonna help towards
drinks and instead of you giving me a
gift you're giving me some the
opportunity to get something that I
actually may want or need so for example
uh coming up like next weekend so the
day after I'm gonna need that money to
go through some other things so you guys
have to help me tonight
[Laughter]
[Music]
um I think we um kind of you know
explained some things and I think uh I
hope people got something from it but um
before we leave I'm just gonna say could
you follow me
um on all my social medias get me to
100K I'm 180k right now on YouTube
um get me to 100K please
um follow Sarah Garvey on all platforms
and if you haven't
or if you have watch two or more of our
videos tell them and you have not
subscribed tell them then we have what
pal beef what do we have beef exactly so
you better get doing that right now
guys a couple announcements before we
end the show I just have you know what
I'm not even gonna do all of them you
already know we have Clips channels you
already know we have membership tears go
subscribe to Pearl behind the scenes
okay I'll be freestyling reacting to
videos like I did in the good old days
the channel oh geez remember when I just
used to react for hours I miss it so go
subscribe to Pearl behind the scenes and
wife School our first episode is
dropping this week like the video on
your way out and we will talk to you
next time